OKAY.
GOOD MORNING --
óRDENES SENATOR UMBERG GOOD
MORNING SENATORS NIELSEN.
A GREAT TO BE HERE --
THIS IS THE FIRST HEARING OF THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER.
FOUR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION AND
GENERAL --
WELL THIS COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE
TOUCHES UPON --
REAL DIVERSE SET OF ISSUES THESE
ISSUES ARE CRITICAL AND IN SOME
CASES LIFESAVING TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN THAT I AM HONORED TO BE
ENTRUSTED WITH CHAIRING THE SUB
COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
JOE STEPHENSON WHERE'S JOE. FOR
THE LIST ABOUT WHAT.
AND YOUNG A YOUNG SALAS FOR
THEIR WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND HELPING ME SO MUCH AND
HELPING THE REST OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK AFTER
MEDIAN WITH MANY OF THE LEADERS
OF THE DEPARTMENTS I WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR TIME.
IN MEETING WITH ME AND ALSO THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT THEY
REPRESENT ACROSS ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS IN STATE GOVERNMENT --
WE ARE THE WHOLE GREAT WORK THAT
EVERYONE DOES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THIS YEAR WE WILL DO A DEEP DIVE.
INCLUDING.
REVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS.
INTO TOPICS LIKE HOUSING.
HOMELESSNESS OUR STATE'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEMS.
OUR AGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
CARING FOR OUR VETERANS.
OUR TAX STRUCTURES.
OUR ELECTIONS INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING THE MONUMENTAL
ENDEAVOR OF CONDUCTING A ROBUST
AND INCLUSIVE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST HOW WE
CAN LEVERAGE OUR STATE'S
PURCHASING POWER. TO REWARD
RESPONSIBLE CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS.
THAT EARN PROFITS WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS.
IN CALIFORNIA OUR IDEAL IS TO
GOVERN FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
INSEPARABLE FROM THIS IDEAL IS
THE IDEA OF PURCHASING FOR THE
COMMON GOOD.
INVESTMENTS SHOULD ALWAYS
STRENGTHEN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
BUILD UPON OUR COLLECTIVE POWER
TO HELP ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MY FELLOW.
ON THIS SUBCOMMITTEE.
OUR COUNTERPARTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND DURING THIS BUDGET PROCESS.
SENATOR NIELSEN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS NOT TO BE
HERE WITH THAT.
THANK YOU.
CENTER OVER WHAT HE SAID.
THIS IS GOING TO BE EASY
[inaudible]
YES.
MAKES YOU SAY THAT ALL THE VOTES
UNKNOWNS.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
OKAY -- WE
NEED TO CALL THE ROLL OKAY.
SENATOR DORADO YES.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY.
I'M SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
TAKE -- THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE VOTE ONLY.
ITEMS --
THESE. THREE OKAY --
I SHOULD DO NAME ONLY
[inaudible]
NAME OF OKAY [inaudible]
OF DOES ANY MEMBER OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WISH TO REMOVE ANY
ITEMS FROM THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. ONE ON ONE A SEPARATE
A SEPARATE.
OKAY.
I'M WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS POINT.
ON THAT ISSUE.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
TO BOATS ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
AND THE FIRST ITEM IS ISSUE
[inaudible]
ONE I'M SORRY.
OKAY SO I NEED A MOTION --
A MOTION TO APPROVE ITEM
[inaudible] ONE ONE OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
AND NOW --
WE NEED TO MOVE THE SECOND IT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR DORADO YES.
SENATOR NIELSEN NO.
CENTER I'M.
OKAY.
THE SECOND VOTE FOR THE VOTEON
THE ISLANDS ARE ISSUES TWO
THROUGH FIVE ON YOUR AGENDA.
IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE THESE
ITEMS.
CENTER NIELSEN.
SECOND IT OKAY.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR DORADO YES SENATOR
NELSON YES SENATOR AMBER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THERE WE GO NOW.
PROPOSED OKAY WE MOVE ON TO
ISSUE.
SIX SO WE'LL HAVE --
THIS CALL.
PLEASE COME UP.
A SECOND.
CHANCE THEY'LL WISH TO BUT WE
DON'T OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
MY HEART [inaudible] EIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS MIRIAM
BARCELONA ENGINEER AL AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH SCALE.
WE ARE CHARGED WITH THE
OPERATIONS MAINTENANCE AND
SUPPORT OF THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE PROVIDED WITH YOU HI
I'M JUST SOME BACKUP MATERIAL ON
IN THE WHITE FOLDERS AS WELL AS
JUST A COPY OF THAT THE SLIDE
DECK THAT I'M JUST GONNA RUN
THROUGH IS.
AS I PROVIDE JUST AN OVERVIEW OF
WHAT THIS GAL IS AND WHERE WE
ARE TODAY.
SO THIS GAL IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST.
AND MOST DYNAMIC IT SYSTEMS AT
THE STATE HAS EVER DEPLOYED --
IT STARTED OFF AS JUST A
BUDGETING REPLACEMENT SYSTEM AND
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE AND A TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN IT WAS
BROUGHT IN TO BASICALLY REPLACE
THE LEGACY SYSTEMS.
OF THE FOR CONTROL AGENCIES THAT
ARE MY PARTNERS SO AT THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
THE PROCUREMENT PIECES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JOHN I FINANCE --
AND AGAIN IT WAS THE PURPOSE FOR
THIS WAS TO PROVIDE THAT
CENTRALIZED A SINGLE SINGLE
SYSTEM OR ALL OF THE INFORMATION
ARE ALL THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION FOR THE STATE COULD
BE FOUND.
SO AND THEN WE PICTURE IT IN IN
THE THE TREES YOU CAN SEE THE
ROOFS ALL GOING OUT IN DIFFERENT
WAYS BUT THEN AGAIN WE'RE COMING
INTO THIS INDUSTRY THAT IS GOING
TO BE A SINGLE SOURCE OF THAT
INFORMATION.
THE THE SIZE OF THE SYSTEM --
IS WHAT MAKES.
THE SIZE AND COMPLEXITY OF THE
SYSTEM IS IS REALLY WHAT MAKES
THIS.
UNIQUE I AGAIN AS YOU KNOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
POPULATION OF IN EXCESS OF
THIRTY NINE MILLION RESIDENTS.
WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AND SO OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT IS IS OPERATING TO
SUPPORT THOSE PEOPLE AND THAT
AND THIS ECONOMY.
THE SYSTEM TODAY HAS ABOUT 65%
OF TOTAL BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES
RUN THROUGH OUR SYSTEM THAT
TOTALS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS --
IN OCTOBER WE BROUGHT ON TO THE
TREASURY FUNCTIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER WHICH
MEANS THAT WE DO ABOUT TWO
TRILLION DOLLARS OF BANKING
HAPPENS WITHIN THE THE FISCAL
SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES THE EIGHT
LARGE BANKS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES BUSINESS WITH.
I'M OUTSIDE OF THE STATE AS WELL
AS THE FIFTY OR SO --
GANG.
MAKE A COUNTER --
ARE AT LARGE PROGRAMS THAT THE
TREASURER MANAGES AS THE BANK
FOR FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
VENDORS THAT DO BUSINESS WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SELLING
GOODS AND SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE.
AND THEY UTILIZE --
THE THE FISCAL SYSTEM AND THE
PLATFORM THAT PRODUCED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
CALLED CAL E. PROCURE.
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND AND
USERS CURRENTLY UTILIZING THE
SYSTEM WE WERE ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED TO BE ABOUT A
THIRTEEN THOUSAND AND USE OUR
SYSTEM.
WHERE --
EIGHTEEN I EXPECT BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR ALL HAVE CLOSER TO
TWENTY THOUSAND AND USERS
BECAUSE I'M STILL ON BOARDING
SOME OF THE USERS FOR THE THE
MOST RECENT DEPARTMENTS THAT
CAME ON AS WELL AS BY THE TIME
WE BRING IN OUR DEFERRED EXEMPTS
DEPARTMENT OR THE DEFERRED.
DEPARTMENTS --
WE WILL PROBABLY BE CLOSER
222-523-0000 AND USERS WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS CURRENTLY IN THE
SYSTEM.
AND IF YOU FLIP TO SLIDE.
SIX I THIS IS JUST A KIND OF A
PICTURE SUMMARIZING SOME OF WHAT
I HAVE ALREADY SAID WE HAVE A
100% OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
WERE INTENDED TO COME ON TO THE
SYSTEM --
ARE DEPLOYED AGAIN WE HAVE ABOUT
NINE DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEFERRED BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN --
ACCOUNTING AN ERP SYSTEM A
MODERN ACCOUNTING SYSTEM.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN PASSED ITS
USEFUL LIFE AT THIS POINT BUT
WHEN WE GET WHEN THEY GET TO
THAT POINT THEY WILL BE COMING
ON TO THE FISCAL SYSTEM.
WE NOW ANY THAT WE SET OUT TO
DEPLOY IS IN --
IS IN THE SYSTEM IN THE
DEPARTMENTS AND CONTROL AGENCIES
ARE UTILIZING THAT FUNCTIONALITY
WE HAVE ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
REQUIREMENTS LAUGHED AND THOSE
PERTAIN TO THE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S CASH BOOK OF
RECORD COMING OVER WE'VE ALREADY
MOVED.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF OTHER
PIECES OF THAT THE THE
CONTROLLER SYSTEM WE JUST
RECENTLY MOVED OVER WARRANTS AND
THEY'RE RUNNING IN PARALLEL
SYSTEM WHICH YOUR STAFF.
RODE UP ABOUT THE INTEGRATED
SOLUTION ON HOW WE'RE RUNNING
SOME OF THE THE CONTROL
FUNCTIONS THROUGH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
IN PARALLEL.
FOR I LIMITED TIME.
SO WE HAVE THAT AS WELL AS THE
BUILDING OUT OF THE AT THE
KAFFIR WHICH IS THE I ALWAYS GET.
THE CONSOLIDATED ACCOUNTING.
IN.
REPORT THANK YOU.
THAT THE CONTROLLER -
DOES PRODUCE THROUGH THROUGH THE
SYSTEM.
THE NEXT COUPLE OF SLIDES JUST --
ILLUSTRATE THE IF SYSTEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN CONSOLIDATED INTO THE
FISCAL SYSTEM REPLACING.
THESE ARE THE KEY LEGACY SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN REPLACED AND THAT
WAS SLIDE.
SEVEN AND THEN ON SLIDE EIGHT IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS IN OUR
LEGISLATIVE REPORT AND IT.
MEASURES US AGAINST THE
LEGISLATIVE OBJECTIVES SET FORTH
IN STATUTE.
AND WE HAVE MET THOSE
LEGISLATIVE EXIT --
OBJECTIVES AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING THE FINAL.
TO SELL ON THE STATUS OF THE
PROJECT.
ON PAGES TEN AND ELEVEN ON PAGE
TEN THE TRANSPARENCY WEBSITE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE EXPECTED TO
FULLY DEPLOY.
IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY NINETEEN
AND WE ARE ON TRACK TO DO THAT
WE ACTUALLY ISSUED AND PUT OUT
THE SITE EARLY AS A PILOT.
WE STARTED WITH FOR DEPARTMENTS
LAST JULY AND WE'RE NOW AT SIXTY
SIX DEPARTMENTS CURRENTLY HAVING
THEIR EXPENDITURE INFORMATION UP
ON THE TRANSPARENCY WEBSITE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENTS THE MINISTRATION. TO
REFINE THE TYPES OF INFORMATION
THAT ARE UP AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS IN FORMATS THAT.
THAT I CAN BE UTILIZED BY ALL SO
AGAIN THAT HAS BEEN WE RECEIVED
POSITIVE FEEDBACK FROM THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ON IT THOSE FOLKS
IT MORE THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE CODES FOR
SACRAMENTO AND AND CODES FOR IT --
MEREKA TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS
CAN TELL THAT OTHER FOLKS HAVE
BEEN ON THE SYSTEM AS WELL.
SO THAT IS ON TRACK AND WE WILL
BE BRINGING ON THE REMAINING
DEPARTMENTS IN --
THAT THIS THIS COMING SUMMER.
THEN THE FINAL PIECE OF THE THE
FUNCTIONALITY AND THE PROJECT
ITSELF IS THE SCO REALLY STATUS.
IN S. P. R. SEVEN WE DID BREAK
DOWN THE RELEASE THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE CONTROLLER
INTO FIVE MAJOR MILESTONES.
AND AGAIN AFTER --
SEVERAL ATTEMPTS AT TRYING.
TO TO CUT OVER THE BOOK OF
RECORD IN ONE FELL SWOOP --
WE DECIDED COLLECTIVELY AS THE
THE FOR PARTNER AGENCIES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH SCALE. TO
BREAK IT INTO --
SEPARATE BUSINESS FUNCTIONS AND
ROLL IT ON ALLOWING FOR SOME
STABILITY SOME STABILIZATION OF
THE SYSTEM AND SOME VALIDATION
FRM THE CONTROLLERTO TO
VALIDATE THAT THE INFORMATION IN
THE SYSTEM.
IS MAKING SENSE WITH THEIR WITH
THEIR BOOK OF RECORD SO LIKE I
SAID WE ARE --
CURRENTLY.
SCHEDULED TO RELEASE THE
REMAINING PARTS OF MILESTONE
THREE AND THEN MILESTONE FOR IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND AS
INDICATED ON SLIDE ELEVEN AND IN
SOME OF THE WRITE UPS OF
OVERSIGHT ENTITIES WE ARE.
CURRENTLY REVIEWING THE TIMELINE
IN THE SCHEDULE.
FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE KAFFIR
FUNCTIONALITY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
REGARDING THE DELAYS --
WILL THEY REQUIRE ANY ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATIONS.
IMAM IN THIS BUDGET YEAR OR IN
THE FUTURE AND SECOND --
WILL ANY OF THE DELAYS --
FOR CHALLENGES TO CLOSING OUT --
MONTH OR YEAR AND REPORTS WILL
THEY RESULT IN A NEGATIVE IMPACT.
WITH REGARD TO OUR FINANCIAL
STANDING.
SO WITH X. WITH THAT TO YOUR
FIRST QUESTION.
WE ARE STILL IN THE ANALYSIS
PHASES TO WHAT COMPONENTS WE
WOULD NEED TO TO MOVE AND HOW
MUCH THAT WILL COST.
AGAIN THE THE TOTAL PROJECT WAS
AT NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS WE SEE WE HAVE
NOT COMPLETELY EXPENDED THOSE
RESOURCES AS OF YET.
SO WHATEVER ASKED WE WOULD COME
TO THE LEDGE.
IF IF THE NINETEEN DIDN'T COVER
THOSE TOTAL EXPENDITURE SO IT'S
IT'S TOO EARLY TO KNOW AT THIS
POINT HOW MUCH --
OR IF WE WOULD BE COMING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES --
BUT WE EXPECT AGAIN THE STEERING
COMMITTEE IS WORKING ON THIS
ENDEAVOR RIGHT NOW AND SO IT IT
WILL BE AND NOW.
IN A MATTER OF A COUPLE OF
MONTHS VERSUS YOU KNOW YEARS
WILL WILL KNOW SHORTLY.
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING THE PROJECT
USING AN AGILE METHODOLOGY OR
THE SPRINTS THIS LAST ASIO
MILESTONE PIECES WHICH MEANS
THAT WE MOVE THINGS FORWARD WHEN
WHEN THEY'RE READY TO GO AND
WE'VE PUSH THINGS OUT WHEN THEY
NEED MORE TIME AGAIN FOCUSING ON
THE QUALITY OF THE PRODUCT.
GOING OUT SO THAT THE SYSTEM.
DOESN'T PRESENT MORE ISSUES.
THAN SAUCE NO WE NEED TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE INFORMATION WE'RE
PUTTING OUT IN THE SYSTEM IS IS
ACCURATE AND SECURE.
SO THAT'S AN OPEN QUESTION.
THEN THE SECOND PIECE WITH
RESPECT TO THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
CLOSING THEIR MINDS [inaudible]
THE I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHAT WE
KNOW WHAT TYPE OF IMPACT THAT
WOULD HAVE ON A CREDIT RATING
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE IN
THE SYSTEM.
WE HAD ONLY FIFTEEN THAT ARE OUR
HEAD.
ESTIMATED STATEMENTS TO THE
CONTROLLER AND THAT WILL BE USED
IN OUR IN THEIR REPORT. TO THE
BOND RATING AGENCIES.
THE YOU KNOW THE HISTORY ON WHAT.
GOES INTO YOUR BOND RATING AND
AND THE STATE'S CREDIT RATING.
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND IF AND AGAIN THE TREASURE TO
SPEAK TO THIS MUCH MORE
ELOQUENTLY THAN I CAN BUT THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY HAD
PROVIDED TO US INDICATED THAT.
THE MAIN REASONS FOR ANY
NEGATIVE MOVEMENT ON THE KAFFIR
HAD BEEN BECAUSE OF LATE BUDGETS
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY.
OR AT SOME SORT OUT WHETHER
VOTER PROPOSITIONS THAT WAS
ANOTHER ONE WHERE YOU TAKE ADAM
IF THERE'S A MAJOR INITIATIVE ON
THE BALLOT THAT.
IS ALLOCATING SPENDING THOSE AT
THOSE PERIODS OF TIMES WE'VE
SEEN A NEGATIVE IMPACT.
OF COURSE YOU KNOW THE THE THE
GLOBAL RECESSION THAT WE HAD AND
WAS THE LAST TIME THAT THAT THIS
WAS IMPACTED.
WE HAVE PRODUCED TO ESTIMATED
STATEMENTS BEFORE IN THE PAST.
THOSE DID NOT RESULT IN NEGATIVE
DOWNGRADES BUT AGAIN.
THAT'S ALL ANECDOTAL WHAT THE
HISTORY AS IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE THE MOST
ACCURATE FINANCIAL RECORDS TO
ADD TO THE CITIZENS AS WELL AS
TO THOSE THAT ARE INVESTING IN
CALIFORNIA BONDS.
AND THAT IS WHAT FISKE OUT IS IS
REALLY STRIVING TO DO SO WE ARE
WORKING WITH THOSE DEPARTMENTS --
WE HAVE RESOURCES THAT ARE ARE
SPENDING MORE TIME WITH THEM --
INCLUDING THE ON BOARDING OF AS
YOU KNOW SOME CONTRA REDIRECTING
SOME OF MY CONTRACTOR STAFF TO
WORK WITH THESE DEPARTMENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE THE
MOST MATERIAL FOR THE STATE OF
ALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THEIR BOOKS ARE CLOSING ON
TIME. ONE OF THE KEY FACTORS FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS TO CLOSE.
IS.
AT EDUCATION AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEIR UNDERSTANDING THE NEW
SYSTEM WE WENT FROM A
TRANSACTIONAL I SYSTEM WHICH WAS
MOSTLY CAL STARS MISS IT
APARTMENTS WERE ON THE CAL STARS
TRANSACTIONAL SYSTEM. TO TRUE
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM AND SO THERE
IS A LEARNING CURVE FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
ENTER.
YOUR EXPENDITURES INTO THE
PROPER LEDGERS AND YOU REVENUES
IN THE PROPER LEDGERS.
AND SO THAT IS AN ONGOING EFFORT
THAT WE HAVE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
IT WITH AGAIN MY FOR PARTNERS.
TO EDUCATE THE DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT RECENTLY
FROM DOING THEIR OWN BOOKS TO
USING THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES CONTRACTED FISCAL
SERVICES. TO AGAIN IF THEY'RE
TOO SMALL.
OR IF THEY HAVE SEPARATION OF
DUTIES ISSUES WITHIN A NEW.
ROBUST ACCOUNTING SYSTEM WE ARE
LOOKING TO TO FIND OTHER WAYS TO
SUPPORT THEM BESIDES JUST.
SAYING HE'S GONNA DO IT FASTER
HIS.
THAT'S HARD THANK YOU HELLO
[inaudible]
OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BRIAN METZGER FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
SO WE LIKE TO ORGANIZE OUR
COMMENTS AROUND --
TO GENERAL TOPIC AREAS THE FIRST
BEING THE DELAYS IN THE
INTEGRATED SOLUTION AND THE
SECOND BEING THE ON GOING
CHALLENGES FOR THE PROJECT --
THE FIRST IS THAT IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED THAT THE INTEGRATED
SOLUTION WILL NOT BE COMPLETED
BY JULY --
TWENTY NINETEEN AT BASED ON THE
SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT THE MOST
RECENT --
ONE WE WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION --
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IS
DIRECTING THE FISCAL PROJECT TO
SUBMIT WHAT IS CALLED A PROJECT
OF THE DOCUMENT THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE CALLING IT --
TO UPDATE --
THE POTENTIAL COST AND SCHEDULE
TO OF THE INTEGRATED SOLUTION
AND POTENTIALLY OTHER TOPICS --
THIS WOULD POTENTIALLY BE IN
LIEU OF A SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT --
BARRING ANY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
AND COST OR SCHEDULE --
THIS PROCESS --
IT WOULD REPRESENTS --
AND HAVE THE SAME AUTHORITY AS A
SPECIAL REPORT PROCESS --
WHICH WOULD BASICALLY SET A
BASELINE BY WHICH THE PROJECT
WOULD BE MEASURED AS FAR AS ITS
COST AND SCHEDULE GOING FORWARD --
BUT AS WE'VE DISCUSSED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS PROCESS IS
CURRENTLY NOT IN STATE I. T.
POLICY -- IT
IS POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE
PROPOSING INTRODUCED BEFORE THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET CYCLE --
HOWEVER WE REMAIN CONCERNED AND
INTRODUCING A NEW PROCESS FOR
UPDATING THE COST AND SCHEDULE
OF PROJECT THE SIZE OF FISCALE --
WITHOUT IT BEING IN STATE I. T.
POLICY --
MAY LIMIT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROCESS --
WE WOULD ALSO BASED ON THAT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT SORRY THE LEGISLATURE
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT --
TO EXPLAIN THE NEW PROCESS --
TO DESCRIBE --
THE AUTHORITY ON WHICH IT RESTS --
TO DESCRIBE.
HOW IT WOULD DIFFER FROM THE
SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT PROCESS --
AS WELL AS TO YOU CAN MENTION
WHAT ROLE THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
PLAY --
UNDER THIS NEW PROCESS.
WE WOULD ALSO WITH REGARDS THE
CHALLENGES THAT I THINK THE
DIRECTOR --
MENTIONED --
WE CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ON BOARDING OF
REMAINING DEPARTMENTS FROM THE
JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN RELEASE --
THAT ARE CONTINUING TO USE
LEGACY SYSTEMS IN ADDITION TO
USING FOR SCALE --
THOSE DEPARTMENTS ARE CONTINUING
TO ARE --
HAVING TO MATE MAY POTENTIALLY
HAVE DELAYS IN CLOSING THEIR
MONTH AND AND YEAR END FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE
TO USE THEIR LEGACY SYSTEMS.
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE DEFERRED DEPARTMENTS THAT
WERE PART OF THE SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT --
THAT ARE ANTICIPATED TO COME
ONLINE TO FISCAL --
BUT ARE NOT CAPTURED IN PROJECT
COST CURRENTLY --
AND WOULD HAVE TO SUBMIT
INDIVIDUAL BUDGET REQUESTS TO
LATER COME ON FISCAL --
AND WE WOULD ALSO NOTE AGAIN
KIND OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS ALREADY FACING WITH
MONTH AND IN YOUR AND CLOSE --
DID APART AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED FIFTEEN HAD TO SUBMIT
ESTIMATED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS.
FOR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ARE THE
DEPARTMENT SAID CAME ONLINE IN
JULY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARE MUCH
LARGER --
AND SO THE RISK OF NOT CLOSING
THOSE MONTH AND IN YOUR AND
STATEMENTS ON TIME --
COULD BE GREATER FOR THE STATE --
AND SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET ME A IN I'M.
TURN TEMPORARILY WHERE THE
CHAIRS AND IN ANOTHER MEETING.
THIS IS A MAYBE PEOPLE TECH KIND
OF INNOCUOUS AREA FORCED
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY YOU
KNOW WE DON'T THINK ABOUT MUCH.
BUT I SUBMIT I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS FOR MANY YEARS.
EVEN AS A CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD
PRISON TERM FOR MANY YEARS WERE.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS WAS
IMPLEMENTING A WHOLE NEW SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT A VERY GOOD RECORD FOR
THE STATE THAT PRIDES ITSELF AN
ITCH TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES AND
LEADERSHIP.
IN FACT TO THE CONTRARY IT'S A
DISGRACE.
ALMOST ALL OF OUR MAJOR TECH
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN WAY OVER
BUDGET.
AND THEY'VE CRASHED [inaudible]
VERY FEW.
CAN WE EVER SAY.
HAVE SERVE THE INTERESTS OF THE
PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S NOT TOLERABLE ANYMORE.
AND I WOULD.
SET FOR THE RECORD THE
OBSERVATIONS OF THE LA ALL RIGHT
NOW.
ARE ABSOLUTELY.
ISSUES THAT I'M GOING TO BE.
STAYING ON FOR THE REST OF MY
CAREER.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE'VE SQUANDERED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND I'M I'M NOT COMFORTABLE.
WITH IMPLEMENTING A NEW PROCESS.
BEFORE WE EVEN UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS.
AND WE'RE AND I FEAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE ADVOCATING
EVEN MORE OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AND AUTHORITY FOR OVERSIGHT.
IT STARTED OUT BEING SOMETHING
CALLED AND I BLACKED OUT OF
KUWAIT OFFICE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND I GUESS IT'S NOW
DO IT I THINK RIGHT.
IT'S THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY YEAH THAT WELL.
NOW THIS DEBT.
AB CHANGE MANY TIMES THAT BUT
THAT IS NOT MY POINT.
THE CHANGING AND MAJOR DECISIONS.
THE ISSUE RELATED TO MILESTONES
IS CRITICAL.
AND WE JUST CANNOT.
HAVE THAT INTIMATE [inaudible]
OVERSIGHT.
OF ALL THE TECHNOLOGICAL
APPLICATIONS AGENCY BY AGENCY.
AND THE MAGNITUDE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH NOW.
WITH THE NUMBERS OF AGENCIES
COMING ON LINE OR PREPARING.
TO UP.
WE NEED EVEN BETTER OVERSIGHT
THAN MILESTONES.
WHAT WOULD YOU SUGGEST THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT WOULD BE
[inaudible]
FISCAL DISCIPLINES.
IF YOU WILL EVEN PENALTIES.
IF CONTRACTORS.
ARE NOT.
COMPLETING THE JOB OR IF YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS NOT.
COMPLETING ITS WORK.
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THEN ON BUDGET.
WHAT SHOULD WE THE LEGISLATURE
DUE TO ENSURE THE OVERSIGHT?
AND CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE
CONTINUED THE LACE AND OVERRIDES.
THERE IS A LOT IN ALL OF THAT.
A LOT BUT IT'S IT'S A CRITICAL
ERROR IT IT ABSOLUTELY ALIENS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND IT'S
AN EMBARRASSMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO PUT A
STAUNCH THE BLEEDING HERE
[inaudible]
SO.
THIS SYSTEM DOES MANAGE
CURRENTLY TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
EXPENDITURES THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
IT DOES CURRENTLY MANAGE THE TWO
TRILLION DOLLARS IN BANKING.
THE DEPARTMENTS CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THEY
ARE NOT BEING ABLE. TO TO PAY
THEIR BILLS TO FUNCTION AND TO
DO THEIR WORK AND THAT IS ALWAYS
WHAT IS KEY FOR US AS WELL AS MY
FOR PARTNERS.
SO IF YOU DEPARTMENT IS COMING
ACROSS AN ISSUE WE WORK
SPECIFICALLY WITH THEM. TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
CRITICAL LIKE FIRE SAFETY ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS DEAL WITH THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO GET THOSE PAYMENTS AND
EXPENDITURES.
OUT THE DOOR --
THAT IS THE WE CANNOT STOP THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
CONSERVING THE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THE I'M WITH RESPECT TO THE TO
THE BUDGET THE BUDGET AND SCOPE
OF THE OF THIS PROJECT HAS SWUNG
SIGNIFICANTLY.
WE STARTED OFF AT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT
WHEN WE WERE JUST THE BUDGETING
SYSTEM SO THAT WAS THE FIRST.
ESTIMATE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAD WE WENT UP AS HIGH AS ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY AT NINE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN THOSE
CHANGES HAPPEN BECAUSE WE'VE
INCREASED OR DECREASED SCOPE
OVER OVER THE YEARS.
AND PART OF THAT HAS OCCURRED
BECAUSE IT IS A LONG PROJECT SO
THINGS THAT WE DECIDED THAT WE
WERE GOING TO NEED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND A CERTAIN WAY
OF DOING IT.
AREN'T NECESSARILY.
WHAT WE NEEDED IN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHEN WE STARTED
DEPLOYING?
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
THROUGH THE THE AMENDMENT
PROCESS THROUGH THE SPR
PROCESSOR OR THROUGH THE UPDATE
PROCESS THAT THE CITY IS
PROPOSING.
THAT.
WE GO IN AND AND WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT.
WHAT WE'RE SPENDING THE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ON STILL MAKE SENSE AND
IF IT DOESN'T THEN WE TAKE THAT
OUT AND WE REMOVE IT FROM THE
SCOUT?
AND SO THAT HAS BEEN THE HISTORY
ON THIS PROJECT SO.
IT.
IT HAS HAD TO COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE SEVERAL TIMES ASKING --
FOR CHANGES TO ITS SCOPE AND
SCHEDULE BUT AGAIN IT IS TO
PRODUCE THAT PRODUCT THAT WILL
PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATION AND
THAT TRANSPARENCY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT --
HAT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS THAT
THE PUBLIC NEEDS AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN UTILIZE TO BETTER
MANAGE THEIR OWN PROGRAMS.
SO.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT YOU KNOW
HAVING FOUR THOUSAND OF THE
FORTY TWO HUNDRED REQUIREMENTS
ALREADY IN PLACE.
IS IS.
REALLY AN INDICATION THAT THE
PROJECT IS SUCCESSFUL WHAT.
IT MAKES IT MORE CHALLENGING AND
MORE DIFFICULT IS AN
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE CHANGE
MANAGEMENT PIECE.
THE CHANGE MANAGEMENT KEYS.
IS THE HARDEST PART --
WE WE CHANGE FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE WAY CALIFORNIA DOES
BUSINESS.
AND THAT MEANS THAT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES HAVE
HAD.
TO DO THEIR JOBS DIFFERENTLY.
I THERE ARE THINGS THAT WERE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
REQUIREMENTS AND POLICY.
AS WELL AS REGULATION THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS WERE EXPECTED TO
COMPLY WITH.
THAT FISCAL SYSTEM. EIGHT IF YOU
WERE UNAWARE OF IT YOU'RE NEW TO
THE STATE YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT
YOU HAD TO GO THROUGH THIS
HURDLE OR THAT HURDLE.
YOU CANNOT PROCEED IN THE SYSTEM
UNTIL YOU'VE FULLY COMPLIED WITH
THE POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT.
INTO THE SYSTEM SO IT DOES
PROVIDE.
A MORE.
ACCURATE.
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM IT IS HARDER
FOR DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE OF THAT
THINGS THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
RECONCILE TWO MONTHS.
DO THEIR BUDGETS AND SO IT IS
MORE THAN JUST THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IT'S WHAT THAT.
TECHNOLOGY MEANS TO THE IT TO
THEIR DAY TO DAY WORK AND AGAIN
I I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE
INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
BEING REQUIRED TO PUT INTO THE
SYSTEM.
IS MORE DETAILED.
THEREFORE LEADING TO MORE
TRANSPARENCY BUT ON THE FLIP
SIDE OF THAT YOU DO HAVE THAT
LEARNING CURVE ON AND HOW YOU
YOU GO ABOUT DOING THAT.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY A HUGE
UNDERTAKING WE ARE THE LARGEST
FINANCIAL ERP SYSTEM --
IN THE POT IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
AND I WOULD ARGUE IN IN THE
WORLD GIVEN WHERE MUCH LARGER
THAN ANY --
IS SO IT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WHILE WE CAN
LOOK TO OTHER STATES OR OTHER
COUNTRIES AND AND HOW THEY'VE
IMPLEMENTED IT WE ARE UNIQUELY
CALIFORNIAN AND WE HAVE.
OUR LAWS AND OUR STRUCTURES THAT
HAVE ADDED TO THE COMPLEXITY OF
THIS IMPLEMENTATION AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS.
SO WELL I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT
IT ISN'T A DIFFICULT FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
IT IS RECOGNIZED THAT THIS.
EFFORT HAS BEEN.
THOUGHTFUL METHODICAL IT HAS
BEEN SLOW BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO IT RIGHT WE DON'T
WANT TO IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY.
TODAY THAT IS GOING TO BE YOU
KNOW OUT OBSOLETE BY THE TIME
FOR FULLY UTILIZING.
ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
UTILIZING THE FISCAL SYSTEM
THERE ARE VERY FEW THERE'S
EIGHTEEN BETTER CURVE --
CALENDARS AT THIS --
CALENDARS AT CAL STARS SORRY --
THEY THE LEGACY ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM SOME OF THAT IS FOR THE
FEDERAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE'RE STILL CAN WE STILL
WORK ON THERE'S ABOUT. SIX OR
EIGHT OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
AND MOST OF THE OTHERS THAT ARE
UTILIZING BOTH SYSTEMS IT'S TO
DO SOME VALIDATION OF SOME OF
THE LAST.
RELEASE ENHANCEMENT SO WE'VE
DONE SOME MOST OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE COMING OFF
OF THEIR GROUPS ARE EXPECTED TO
COME OFF OF CAL STARS.
AT THE END OF MARCH SO IT'S IF
THEY'RE NOT DOING TO COMPLETE.
DUPLICATE SYSTEMS IT'S REALLY
SOME OF THEM ARE USING CAL START
TO DO SOME OF THE REPORTING THAT
THEY CAN'T GET OUT OF THE FISCAL
SYSTEM.
SUMMER DOING I USING IT --
FOR PAYMENT TO FOREIGN VENDORS
BECAUSE AGAIN THAT'S AN AREA
THAT WE'RE STILL WORKING ON IT
WITH OUR PARTNERS --
BUT FOR THE FOR THE BULK OF THE
TRANSACTIONS IN THE BULK OF THE
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING SPENT BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE.
FOREIGN TRACKED WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM WELL YOU TRACKING BUT
THERE ARE NO CONSEQUENCES WHAT
ARE THE CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE
CONTINUED DELAYS.
I WANT TO GET THAT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE WE CAN THEN
EFFECT CONSEQUENCES.
THAT THERE SOME KIND OF PENALTY.
TO THE CONTRACTOR.
OR TO THE DEPARTMENTS THEY THEY
CAN'T JUST KEEP DOING THIS AND
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE BUT YOU'VE
GOT ANY MECHANISMS IN THERE. TO
MAKE THEM REALLY ACCOUNTABLE
MAYBE IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
TRANSPARENT THAT IS STILL
ACTIVITIES THIS PROCESS IS THAT
YOU'RE.
DEALING WITH NOW IS GOING TO
EVEN GIVE US A LET LESSER
ABILITY TO OVERSEE AND IMPLEMENT
CONSEQUENCES WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE CONTINUED
FAILURES.
SO THERE ARE CONTRACT
CONTRACTUAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
EXTENSION OKAY DO YOU EVER
EMPLOYED THE YES WE HAVE AND I
CAN PHONE A FRIEND IF YOU WANT
TO KNOW HOW MUCH THAT.
JUST YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE TO AS IT COSTS THESE
BUSINESSES SUBSTANTIAL MONEY I
HOPE AT I WOULD IMAGINE SO.
ON ABOUT THE STATE AGENCIES AND
WITH RESPECT TO THE STATE
AGENCIES ARE YOU REFERRING TO
THE CONTROL THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROJECT OR
THE UTILIZATION OF THE PRODUCT.
SO WITH EITHER ONE HAVE WORKED
WITH CAGE WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROJECT WE
DID BREAK IT DOWN INTO THE
MILESTONES AND LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE DID TILE HI THE
MILESTONES. TO SUM APPROPRIATION
DOLLARS FOR FOR THE SO THAT
MECHANISM.
IS IN PLACE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE.
TO SUCCESSFULLY DELIVER ON THE
BUT I BELIEVE WILL BE AT THE THE
FOUR MILESTONES WE HAVE A GOOD
WAY AT THE FIFTH MILESTONE.
COMPLETED BUT BECAUSE OF
RESOURCES CONSTRAINTS OR ISSUES
THAT COME UP ON A PROJECT THIS
COMPLEX AS WE'RE TRYING TO
REPRODUCE.
INFORMATION IN THE LEGACY SYSTEM
THAT IS UTILIZED REDUCE THE
KAFFIR.
WE HAVE COME UP WITH ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE INITIALLY
KNOWN RECOGNIZED AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE IN PLACE
SO INSTEAD OF JUST AGAIN
BUILDING.
WHAT WE WERE BUDGETED AND WHAT
WE HAD SCOPED?
WE ARE LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET THE SCOPE RIGHT TO
PRODUCE THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
NEED AND NOT JUST.
YOU KNOW MAKING MAKING THE DATES
SO THAT IS HOW YOU KNOW THE
CONTROL AGENCIES HAVE BEEN --
MOST RECENTLY BEEN BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE DELIVERY OF
THE FUNCTIONALITY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE DEPARTMENTS
WE ARE.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
WE HAVE PROVIDED AND WHAT WE
CALL USER SUPPORT LABS WEEK THEY
BRING IN THEIR TRANSACTIONS INTO
MY DEPARTMENT.
THEY SIT WITH THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS EITHER FROM MY
DEPARTMENT WITH DEPARTMENT
FINANCES STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE AS NEEDED DEPENDING ON
THAT ISSUE.
AND WE HELP THEM WORK THROUGH
WHAT THERE'S DON I'M MORE.
LABS IN THE WITH THIS FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF THE FISCAL YEAR THAN
WE DID IN ALL OF LAST YEAR.
AND WE HAVE.
WE DON'T EXPECT TO SLOW DOWN ON
THAT SO WE'RE PROVIDING MORE
HANDS ON KEYS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM WE ALSO HAVE A SIGNED --
WHAT WE HAD BEEN DOING IS HAVING?
WHAT IT COLUMN READY MISS
CORNERS TO PART WITH TO HELP
DEPARTMENTS COME ON TO THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE REPURPOSE THOSE
READING THIS COORDINATORS? TO BE
KIND OF THE THE DEPARTMENTAL
LIAISONS AND HAD LEARNT WHAT ARE
YOUR ISSUES BEFORE THEY KNOW THE
ISSUES SOMETIMES WE CAN SPOT THE
ISSUES.
AND HELP THEM HEY I I REALIZE
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF TICKETS AND
THEY ARE I'M GONNA DO A SPECIAL
LAB JUST FOR YOU BECAUSE YOUR
ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE --
TRANSACTIONS AREN'T.
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE IN THE
SYSTEM SO THAT IS SOMETHING NEW
THAT WE ARE DOING NOW THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SHIFT RESOURCES
FROM?
ONBOARDING DEPARTMENTS TO
ACTUALLY SUPPORTING THEM AND SO
WE ARE HOPING TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS IN THAT REGARD --
AND THEN AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT
FISCALE DOESN'T HOLD ANY --
ANY STICKS WERE JUST WE CAN
PROVIDE CARE TO MAKE A PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
DEPARTMENT PORTION THE CONTRACTS
AND WE DEPEND ON THE PART OF THE
GENERAL SERVICES.
NOTE WE MANAGE OUR CONTRACT OKAY.
THAT SO YOU WERE THE ONE THAT
CAN PENALIZES A CONTRACTOR WHO
DOES NOT MEET THE MILESTONES ARE
COMPLY WITH THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACT WITH THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACT YES AND I DON'T KNOW IF.
JENNY SAID THAT THIS HAPPENED A
ONCE OR ONCE OR TWICE ARTS
HAPPEN SOMETIME CORRECT CAN I
ASK --
PLANNING ON YOUR JUST COME ON UP.
JUST TO PROVIDE THE THE
BACKGROUND ABOUT HOW OFTEN ITS
USE THAT THE SIZE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE H. A
HIGH AND CHIEF DEPUTY AFTER FOR
THE BOND FOR SCALE.
ALSO THE PROGRESS OF A PREDATOR
FISCAL.
SO WE HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
ACCENTURE --
AND THERE.
A DIFFERENT MECHANISMS IN THE
CONTRACT TO HOLD ACCENT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE SERVICE
LEVELS.
AND WE HAVE USED THAT IN THE
PAST SO --
IN A COUNTRY THAT SERVICE LEVELS
FOR RESOLUTION OF TICKETS.
AND TIME YEARS LOOSEN UP SYSTEM --
ISSUES IN THE SYSTEM.
AND ON A PERIODIC BASIS WHERE
IT'S CENTER HAS MISSED.
THE SERVICE LEVELS HI THERE WE
HAVE GIVEN US CREDIT OVER THE
YEARS.
I DON'T HAVE THE THE EXACT
AMOUNT OF THE CREDITS WE RECEIVE
FROM EXTENSION.
OF YOU HAVE HAD.
SEVERAL OF THOSE INSTANCES WHERE.
THEY HAVE MEANT MISSED THE MARK
ON THE SERVICE THAT WAS IN
PENALTIES [inaudible]
WELL THAT.
I'M STILL NOT.
OVERLY CONFIDENT OF WHERE WE'RE
HEADED OKAY.
AT AND MADAM CHAIR MIKE THE
FUNDAMENTAL POINT I MAKE IS
CALIFORNIA OVER DECADES IS
SQUANDERED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON TECHNICAL APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE NOT WORKED BEEN OVER BUDGET.
ALWAYS DELAYED ALWAYS DELAYED
AND DO OUR DAUGHTER WHAT
WHATEVER WE'VE CALLED IT OVER
THE YEARS.
AS SUPPOSED TO BEEN THE AGENCY
TO AFFECT CHANGE AND WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT TO MY OPINION
SIGNIFICANTLY YET.
AND WE HAVE TO GET MAKE SURE OF
THAT AS WE PROCEED AND I'M AWARE
OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
LANGUAGE.
CERTAINLY IS A MEMBER THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND VICE CHAIR I'VE
BEEN A PART OF THAT.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO MORE SO I'M
SUGGESTING THAT WE AS A
COMMITTEE HAVE TO BE VERY
FASTIDIOUS IN?
AS WE PROCEED TO AUTHORIZE
BUDGETS.
FOR THIS AGENCY.
AND THE DEPARTMENTS THERE IT.
THAT WE HAVE TO EFFECT A DIRECT
OVERSIGHT.
IN OUR ABILITY TO PULL IN THE
RANGE.
PERIODICALLY SO --
WE CAN'T WAIT AROUND AND DO THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET AND THEN STE FULL
OF THE YEAR WE COME BACK TO
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND WELL HOW
YOU DOING.
WE CAN'T WAIT THAT LONG.
THAT IN AND NOT BE IN PERSONAL
THERE'S MANY GOOD PEOPLE IN YOUR
AGENCY THAT I DON'T TAKE IT
PERSONAL.
BUT IT'S JUST BEEN A LONG TIME.
HEMORRHAGE AND WE NEED TO STOP
THE BLEEDING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER NEAR --
FIFTY THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL.
I'M SORRY JUST A FEW QUESTIONS
YES.
JUST JUST COUPLE QUESTIONS HERE --
FIRST OF ALL I THINK IS CENTER
NIELSEN JUST ILLUSTRATED.
YOU HAVE A TOUGH JOB SO.
SO MS IS MISS BARCELONA IN THE
NEEDLE.
IS SOLD ON DISC JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS WHAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
BUDGET FOR THIS PROJECT.
IT WAS A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THAT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
AND IT ONLY REPLACE THE
BUDGETING SYSTEM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT?
THE COMPLEXITY IT WAS A ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR PRICE
TAG -- FOR
WHEN WE BROUGHT IN THE FOR
CONTROLLING THERE'S A START AT
ONE FORTY AND YOU SAID IT WAS IT
NINE EIGHTEEN IS THAT TODAY.
CORRECT BUT IT'S GOING TO GO TO
ONE POINT SIX NO IT WAS AT ONE
POINT SAY I IN THE MIDDLE IT
WENT UP AND THEN.
SO IT'S AT NINE EIGHT THAT'S OF
PROJECTED COST TO COMPLETION.
CORRECT AND ACCENTURE IS THE
PRIME YES IN OF THE BEEN THE
PRIME SINCE THE BEGINNING YES I
HAVE.
BEEN ON IN TWENTY TWELVE AND NOT
NOT FOR TODAY BUT FOR THE FUTURE
PERHAPS OF IF YOU COULD LET US
KNOW.
WHAT CHANGES EXPANDED THE SCOPE
ANOTHER WORDS US FOR CERTAIN SHE
WHEN I SAY YOU I I REALIZE THIS?
WAS LONG BEFORE YOU WERE PERCENT
CHARGE BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
CHANGES THAT THAT WE ASK FOR WE
MEAN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT EXPANDED THE SCOPE YOU CAN
EXPECT THE CONTRACTOR. TO
BASICALLY SUCK THAT UP.
THEN THERE ARE CERTAIN CHANGES
THAT WE THOUGHT NO THERE
PROBABLY WITHIN THE SCOPEIS
THAT RIGHT.
OKAY SO MAYBE IF YOU COULD BREAK
THAT DOWN FOR US FOR FUTURE
HEARING JUST WHAT WE THINK WAS
WITHIN WITHOUT.
IN TERMS OF PENALTIES CENTER
NIELSEN'S POINT WHAT PENALTIES
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
IN OTHER WORDS YOU'VE CUT THEM
BACK SOME PLACES IF YOU HAVE IF
YOU COULD JUST LET US KNOW THAT --
YOU SAID IT'S AT 98%
FUNCTIONALITY RIGHT NOW IS THAT
RIGHT OKAY SO WE HAVE FOUR
THOUSAND OF I BELIEVE FORTY TWO
HUNDRED REQUIREMENTS --
DEVELOPING DEPLOYED BUILT TESTED
DEPLOYED.
IN THERE WAS A PROJECT OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY PROJECT ARE
YOU FAMILIAR WITH THAT PROJECT.
OKAY THAT WAS THE CONTROLLERS
PAYROLL PROJECT RIGHT IF YOU
ASSUME THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
PROJECT AT THIS POINT.
WE HAVE NOT SO WHAT THEY WERE
ARMED.
BOTH PROJECTS WERE STARTED
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME TIME AND
THEY WERE ENVISIONED TO RUN IN
PARALLEL AN INTERFACE TOGETHER
AT AT SOME POINT --
WE ARE INTERFACING TO SOME OF
THE OUR SYSTEM RIGHT NOW.
AND WE HAD TO CUSTOMIZE A COUPLE
OF PIECES IN OUR SYSTEM --
UNTIL WE HAVE.
THE LONGER TERM SOLUTION --
FROM WHATEVER PAYROLL SYSTEM WE
ULTIMATELY SO WHEN WILL THAT
HAPPEN.
YOU'D HAVE TO ASK THE CONTROLLER
SORRY.
BUT IT AIN'T FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE SAID IS GOING TO BE.
IN --
OPERABILITY IS THAT RIGHT IT'S
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WE
CREE LEGACY SYSTEM WE CURRENTLY --
HAVE INFORMATION THAT COMES FROM
THEIR LEGACY SYSTEM CORRECT BUT
BUT SOME DAY.
I UNDERSTAND LEGACY SYSTEMS
BASED ON KOBOL AND EVERYBODY IN
THE ROOM THAT UNDERSTANDS WHAT
COBLE IS RAISE THEIR HAND.
ROLL OVER.
FIFTY MAYBE SIXTY ANYWAY THAT
THAT OPERATES ON THE COLD BALL
SYSTEM RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK IT DOES IN ANY EVENT AT
ANY OF IT SO THAT'S THAT'S KIND
OF OUT OF DATE.
ROM.
IN ANY SENSE OF WHEN THAT SYSTEM
WILL BE INTEROPERABLE WITH YOUR
SYSTEM.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THEY'RE IN --
EARLY PHASES OF DEVELOPMENT --
TO PLAN THAT I BELIEVE I HAVE
FOLKS HERE FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THAT WOULD
BE BETTER ABLE.
TO SPEAKER --
TO THE STATUS OF THE I THINK
RECALLING BUT IT'S CALLED
SOMETHING DIFFERENT YEAH.
WE'LL WE'LL LEAVE THAT FOR
ANOTHER DAY --
OKAY.
I THINK TO CENTER NIELSEN'S
POINT THAT WE WILL NEED A
PERHAPS A DEEPER DIVE --
ON THIS AND LASTLY AGAIN.
YOU HAVE MY SYMPATHIES SO.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR --
YES.
JUST THE PHENOMENA THAT
[inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
KIND OF INSTITUTIONALIZED.
THEN IT'S THE PRODUCT TO THE
GREAT TO LIKE NICK TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES.
BUT I FEAR THAT.
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS OVER THE
DECADES.
EITHER BY THE PROVIDER OF OR
MAYBE BY THE AGENCIES.
WE HAVE HAD NEW TECHNOLOGY.
KIND OF THE CHARMING MEETING.
TEMPTING US.
AND SO WE GET DOWN THE TRACK ON
SOMETHING WITH CONTRACTED FOR
NOW THAT'S ALL OLD.
AND NOW WE HAVE SOMETHING NEW.
THE NEWEST RATE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCE IN THIS AREA WHAT NO NO
WE HAVE TO THROW THAT ALL AWAY.
AND NOW WE HAVE.
EMPLOY THE NEW.
SO I WANT US TO BE AWARE OF THAT
NOW THERE'S NEW PROCESS
[inaudible]
CAN YOU.
REALLY LAID OUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY HOW THAT'S GONNA
LOOK BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE I HAVE
A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED LA --
HAS BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT.
SENATOR I BELIEVE THAT THAT
QUESTION IS MORE --
IT IS BETTER ANSWERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AS THE
RECEIPT AS THE RECEIVER OF THE
REQUIREMENT WE WILL PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY WITH
WHATEVER INFORMATION THEY ARE.
THEY'RE ASKING US. TO CONTINUE
ON THE PROJECT IN THEIR ROLE AS
YOU KNOW OUR OVERSIGHT AND
EIGHTY OR ONE OF OUR OVERSIGHT
ENTITIES.
THE MY UNDERSTANDING OF IT AND
AGAIN I DO KNOW THAT CD T. IS
HERE AS WELL AND CAN SPEAK TO
THIS MORE THOROUGHLY BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT BECAUSE WE
ARE USING AN AGILE
IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT.
OUT WE ARE NOT TO THE PROJECT
THAT DON IT'S REALLY THE TIMING
OF THAT THE LAST.
NO 2% OR SO BUT AGAIN.
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THAT
DOCUMENT WILL WILL LOOK LIKE AT
THIS POINT --
WE'RE STILL.
EVALUATING KIND OF THE
COMPONENTS THAT WE NEED TO GO
INTO WHETHER THAT COMPONENT WE
AGAIN BUT I DO BELIEVE CITY TEAM
WOULD BE ABLE TO ANSWER THEM I
HOPE SO BECAUSE I'D CERTAINLY
LIKE TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WAY
BEFORE THE BUDGET JUST FINALIZE
THIS YEAR.
THANK.
NUMBER [inaudible]
THIRTY TWO OKAY --
TO MOVE ON TO THE COMMENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
NOTE.
ONCE OKAY NO PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
RIGHT --
THERE'S NO.
ACTION THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
ITEM ONLY SO THERE'S NO MOTION
NO ACTION TO BE TAKEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU.
THIS.
ISSUE [inaudible]
SEVEN OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE --
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US.
RIGHT WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO IT --
ISSUE SEVEN WONDERFUL JUST LIKE --
QUICKLY OF INTRODUCTION INTO
STEM CELLS AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES.
I'LL BE COVERING ISSUES SEVEN
THROUGH TEN TODAY ALL MY
COLLEAGUE HERE MISTER KENNY THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE REAL
ESTATE SERVICES DIVISION WILL
COVER THE CAPITAL OUTLAY ITEMS.
AS WELL AS THE ISSUE --
FOURTEEN ALSO LIKELY TO KNOW DR
JUST WANNA THANK YOU SENATOR --
DRAWS -- FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY WITH YOU IN
DIRECTOR CAME YESTERDAY FOR THE
FOR TO MEETING WITH YOU CENTER
NUMBER AGAIN RECONNECTING CENTER
NIELSEN AS WELL WE'RE BOTH ON
THE COUNTER FOR BOTH OF YOU BUT
WE MISSED IT IN TIME FOR THIS
FIRST HEARINGS I DO APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT.
THE FIRST ITEM ISSUE SEVEN IS A
REQUEST TO APPROVE --
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE FINANCIAL MARKET
PLACE PROGRAM THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT IS --
BEING EXISTED IN OUR PROCUREMENT
DIVISION THE NINETIES --
IT THE CODE FOR THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN LAST UPDATE IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN ESSENTIALLY IT
TAX EXEMPT FINANCING PROGRAM FOR
DEPARTMENTS YOU NEED TO MAKE
LARGE PURCHASES. TO ALLOW THEM
TO DO THAT AT A VERY LOW
INTEREST RATE --
AND SPREAD THE COST OUT OVER
SEVERAL YEARS IT'S OF ZORBING
THAT COSTS IN ONE YEAR --
THE PART OF FINANCE YOUR AND
TECHNICAL UPDATE TO ENSURE THAT
THIS PROGRAM CONFORMS WITH OTHER
STATE FINANCING PROGRAMS OFFERED
BY OTHER STATE AGENCIES --
AND IS IN CLOSE COLLABORATION
WITH THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ARE PASSED ON TO
MY COLLEAGUES OF FINANCE TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION.
OKAY [inaudible]
BRENT.
HOW INCREASING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THAT LANGUAGE
[inaudible]
WE COULD --
I'M SORRY.
LA OF SALLY WE CAN BUILD PART OF
FINANCE ACTUALLY.
MY COLLEAGUE IS FROM L. L. --
I JUST WANTED TO GIVE SOME
BACKGROUND AS TO WHY WE ARE.
INTRODUCING THIS TRAILER BILL ON
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION AND IRS HAVE
INCREASED THE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT --
MUNICIPAL ISSUANCES ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY FOR TAX EXEMPT
FINANCING'S.
GS MARCH THE GOAL THAT'S
SHORTHAND FOR THE GOLDEN AND
SINGS ARE CONSIDERED AN ISSUE
ONCE OF MUNICIPAL SECURITIES BY
THE STATE.
AND SUCH AS FINANCING SADDAM
HAVE UNINTENDED EFFECTS ON THE
STATE'S OTHER FINANCING PROGRAMS
ABSENT PROPER COORDINATION --
SO THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO
THE CURRENT STATUTE GOVERNING
THE GS SMART PROGRAM WILL ENSURE
INCREASED COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN GS SMART
AND OTHER MAJOR STATE FINANCING
PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING THOSE MANAGED BY THE
S. TEO AND THE STATE PUBLIC
WORKS BOARD --
TOO COMPLICATED STE THE TRAILER
BILL ADDS LANGUAGE TO REQUIRED
YES AND A TO OBTAIN.
TREASURES OFFICE AND FINANCE
APPROVAL FOR TERMS AND
CONDITIONS USED THE GS MARK
PROGRAM.
M. TO AVOID INCONSISTENCIES WITH
OTHER STATE FINANCING --
DESERVE BETTER ENSURE THAT STATE
SPEAKS TO THE MARKET AND ONE
CONSIST.
I IT ALSO REQUIRES DDS TO
PROVIDE NOTICED OF EACH
TRANSACTION TO FINANCING THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE OF THAT
THE G. SMART FINANCINGCAN BE
COORDINATED WITH OTHER STATE
FINANCINGS.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE IRIS TIMING
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE EXIT
EXCUSE ME PROTECT STATE TAX
EXEMPT.
ISSUANCES ARE MET.
ALSO -- AS
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE THE GS MARK
PROGRAM TO USE LAW FIRMS THAT
ARE PULLED FROM A LIST OF BOND
COUNSEL FIRMS.
THEIR PRE QUALIFIED FOR THE OF
BY FAMILIARITY WITH STATE --
ON TAX EXEMPT FINANCING'S AND
ADDS CAN CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS
TO CONFORM TO CURRENT PRACTICE
OF OTHER STATE MUNICIPAL ISSUE
RESEARCH ISSUERS ARE --
I'D ALSO NOTE THAT WE WERE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE TREASURES
OFFICE ON THIS ITEM AND THEY ARE --
IN CONCURRENCE WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND ONE LAST NOTE IS
THAT THE AMENDMENTS --
DO NOT PRECLUDE --
DS WILL STILL BE THE
IMPLEMENTING --
ENTITY FOR THIS PROGRAM WITHOUT
A BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SIR NIELSEN [inaudible]
NOW.
NOW TO START YOUR YEARS SIMPLY
ASKING PLACE HOLDER LANGUAGE IN
THE TRAILER BILL IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING --
IT'S AMENDMENT TO CURRENT
STATUTES AMENDMENT TO GIVE CARS
STATUTES [inaudible]
OKAY WELL.
I'M BEING A LITTLE NIT PICKY BUT
NOT.
NOW WE ARE DOING SO MUCH MORE.
UNCONSCIONABLE A IN TRAILER
BILLS.
TRAILER BILL HISTORICALLY HAVE
BEEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPLEMENTING THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BUDGET.
IN OVER YEARS.
THAT HAS BEEN VERY LOOSELY
INTERPRETED.
WHERE BY NOW WE'RE DOING MAJOR
POLICY CHANGES I DO NOT SUGGEST
JUSTICES MAY BE A MAJOR POLICY
CHANGE THAT WE'RE DOING MAJOR
POLICY CHANGES IN BUDGET?
TRAILER BILL.
THERE ARE NO POLICY COMMITTEE
HEARINGS WE HAD ONE HUGE ISSUE
JUST LAST YEAR THE ONLY HEARING
WAS HELD AND UP.
FOR AND THERE WERE FOUR MEMBERS
SITTING THERE.
AT THE TIME.
THAT'S VERY INADEQUATE
PARTICIPATION SO I WOULD HOPE
FOR SOMETHING LITTLE STRONGER
THAN.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
SOMETHING THAT WOULD.
CONSTITUTE A BILL IN ITSELF
WHERE IT WAS EXAMINED AND THEN
THE POLICY COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
TOWARD THE RIGHT END.
FINANCE WOULD HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT AND THEREFORE I WOULD
HOPE THE LEGISLATURE WITH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS --
THE COMMENT [inaudible]
ANYBODY [inaudible]
NO.
OKAY -- I DO
HAVE ONE QUESTION --
IS THIS FINANCING PROGRAM HAVE
ANY A MEASURES TO ENSURE THAT --
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE PRIORITIZING
THE PROCUREMENT OF OF
RESPONSIBLE SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES.
THIS IS THE SENATOR THE IT AT
THIS TIME THE FINANCING PROGRAM
DOES NOT THE FINANCING PROGRAMS
A MECHANISM --
FOR DEPARTMENTS TO PAY FOR HE
PURCHASED IT WOULD BE THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS IN WHICH
THOSE PROVISIONS WOULD BE
INCLUDED IN WHICH IS A SEPARATE
PART OF THE THE PURCHASING
PROCESS [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT --
NO MORE QUESTIONS --
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ADOPT A PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY
WITH.
TIAS SMART PROGRAM AND OTHER
STATE FINANCES AND STRENGTHEN
THE COMMUNICATION WITH OTHER
STATE FINANCING PROGRAMS FOR
YOUR MOTION [inaudible]
LIMON OKAY [inaudible]
WE THE ROLL CALL YES SENATOR
DRAWS THEM YES.
SENATOR NELSON NO.
SENATOR ON FOR OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT ISSUE THANK YOU ISSUE A IS
REQUESTING I TRAVEL PROGRAM I
WILL OF OUR COLLEAGUE --
FRIEND JAMES AND JOIN US IS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF ENERGY TO SEE
SUPPORT PROGRAM WHO OVERSEES THE
TRAVEL PROGRAM --
JUST BY WAY OF OF BRIEF
INTRODUCTION THIS IS A REQUEST
FOR INCREASED ENOUGH ALREADY --
TO THE SERVICE REVOLVING FUND IN
TGS WHICH ADMINISTERS THIS
PROGRAM --
FOR OF APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE PURPOSE
OF THE INCREASE IS IS TO
ESSENTIALLY PHILIP PROMISE THAT
WE MADE TO DEPARTMENTS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN WE CREATED THE
PROGRAM.
SO WE UPGRADED STATEWIDE TRAVEL
PROGRAM SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE
IDEAS THAT WE WOULD COMBINED ALL
PURCHASING POWER OF THE STATE
AND ALSO HAVE A SINGLE PLACE FOR
ALL TATE TRAVEL TO TO TAKE
PLACE THROUGH.
MAKING EASIER THERE FOR BOTH
USERS OF TRAVEL --
TO BOOK THE TRAVEL AND ALSO
MAKING MORE EFFICIENT FOR THE
STATE TO MANAGE ACCOUNT FOR THAT
TRAVEL.
THAT GOT COLLABORATION WE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING REVENUE IN
THE FORM OF INCENTIVES FROM OUR
TRAVEL PARTNERS IS AND WERE ABLE
TO PASS ALONG THE SAVINGS TO
STATE DEPARTMENTS.
WHO ARE CURRENTLY PAYING BOOKING
FEES?
THE PROPOSAL FOR YOU BEFORE YOU
FOR THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
WOULD GO TO OFFSET BOOKING FEES --
FOR HOTELS AND RENTAL CARS WHICH
I THINK IS AN IMPORTANT POINT IN
THIS DISCUSSION SO WE HAVE AT
THIS POINT JOHN SERVICES
GENERATE ENOUGH REVENUE TO
OFFSET THE FIVE DOLLAR BOOKING
FEE THAT DEPARTMENTS CURRENTLY
PAY. FOR HOTEL AND RENTAL CAR SO
WE'RE BASICALLY ASKING FOR AN
INCREASE IN THAT ALREADY TO THEN
PAY THAT BOOKING FEE ON BEHALF
OF DEPARTMENTS --
AND WERE YOU DOING THAT WITH
MONEY THAT WE'RE RECEIVING FROM
THE TRAVEL VENDORS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM WITH
THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND LOOK FOR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
YES JUST WAIT.
I'M SORRY WILL HAVE A SCAN OF
THE LA ISLAND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE OR
WITH THE PROPOSAL I SHOULD SAY
THE QUESTION.
IS DOES THIS MEAN THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO REBOOK
OURSELF WITH TICKETS WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO THROUGH A TRAVEL
AGENCY.
OR CELLS PERSONALLY THAT I CAN
ACTUALLY DO IT MYSELF.
SO I I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S TRAVEL PRACTICES
PER SE -- I
THANK YOU ALL FOR FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE TRAVEL OFFICE TO
BOOK YOUR TICKETS AND YOU CAN.
BOOK SOUTHWEST TICKETS THROUGH
OUR CONCUR SYSTEM BOTH THROUGH
TRAVEL AGENTS AND THROUGH OUR
WEBSITE.
SO.
IT'S THROUGH THE THE ORGANIZED
CHURCH.
OKAY DOES THAT MEAN I CAN BOOK
MY TICKET.
DIRECTLY OR DO I STILL HAVE TO
GO THROUGH.
SOME TRAVEL AGENCY.
CENTER TO ADD TO POINTS OF THIS
THE STATE WIDE HEALTH PROGRAM IS
AND IS MANDATORY FOR STATE
DEPARTMENTS AS AN OPTIONAL
PROGRAM FOR OTHER ENTITIES ITS
ACTUALLY USED BY SEVERAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
I BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE USES
THAT ARE ON TRAVEL TRAILER NADER
TO BOOK THEIR TRAVEL TO DO --
SO IT IT'S YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION FOR YOUR TRAVEL IS KIND
OF OUTSIDE THE PERSONAL OUT OF
OKAY GENERAL BUT A GENERAL STATE
PLAY YOU NEED TO RE BOOK A
FLIGHT WOULD YOU JUST TRAVEL
SYSTEM CORRECT.
AWKWARD THAT I CAN'T.
WITHOUT INCURRING ANY ADDITIONAL
STATE EXPENSE CHANGE MY FLIGHT
FROM ONE O'CLOCK FLIGHT TO A
THREE O'CLOCK FLIGHT WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH.
A COUPLE DIFFERENT.
ENTITIES BUT OKAY GOT IT
[inaudible]
COULD QUESTIONS [inaudible]
YES SIR.
ON THAT POINT IS IN THIS AN
AUTOMATIC A INVITATION FOR
CONTINUING RAISING THE BOOKING
FEES THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE COULD BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
LIMITED ON WHAT YOU'RE GONNA PAY
IN THE BOOKING FEE WHATEVER THE
BOOKING FEE AS ASKED SO SENATOR
ACTUALLY THE THE BOOKING FEES
ARE CONTRACTED THEY'RE
CONTRACTED THROAT TRAVEL
MANAGEMENT SERVICE PROVIDER IN
ITS COMPETITIVE.
SO ACTUALLY IF ANYTHING GOOD THE
MORE VOLUME WE BRING TO THE
PROGRAM THE THE LOWER THE FEET
SOMETHING LIKE A ONE TIME.
COULD HOLD --
MOVE ON TO I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
READ LIKE TO HEAR ON PUBLIC
COMMENT.
FIRST TURN.
GOOD MORNING AYE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RENE BAYARDO SO YOU
CALIFORNIA I WOULD JUST START BY
SAYING I HAVE THE SAME CONCERN
WITH CONCUR A SENATOR UMBERG.
SO -- ACTS
ARE COMING TO MORE GENERAL TO
THE PROGRAM WE THINK IT'S GREAT
THAT THE STATE IS TRYING TO
UTILIZE ITS PURCHASING POWER WE
THINK IT'S PART OF THAT IN OUR
P. PROCESS THAT THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL TO REALLY.
ASK QUESTIONS OF THOSE THAT WE
CONTRACT THEY'RE HELD TO HIGH
STANDARDS AND ALSO THAT THAT
GOES DOWN CHANGE TO THAT --
IF.
AIRLINE X. --
CONTRACTS WITH SO COUNTER SO
CHARACTER WHAT SUBCONTRACTOR WHY
THAT ARE ALSO MEETING THE SAME
STANDARD SO WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
I WORK IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE CHAIR --
WILL CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
BUT WE HAVE SOME --
MEMBERS HERE TODAY THAT WANT TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS AS WELL ABOUT
THE ABOUT THE PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS SHARON PERRY JUNIOR
AND I WITH THE G. TWO SECURE
STAFF THE SETTLERS AIRPORT AND
ARM OF A WHEELCHAIR ASSISTANT AT
THE AIRPORT ASSIST OUR
PASSENGERS WITH DEALERS THIS
ABILITY. TO A TO A FROM THE
AIRCRAFT.
AND I'M ALSO WITH THE US W. W.
SEIU UNION AS A SHOP STEWARD IS
I WILL WORK ON A CONTRACT TO GET
MORE AFFORDABLE.
HEALTH CARE WHICH WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH RIGHT NOW WITH THE
WHAT THE A ALLOWED OUR OUR
COMPANY ASSOCIATED WITH
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
AS WELL AS THE STATE TRAVEL
PROGRAM WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK IS
THE ADDRESS --
THAT'S DID IN A MEDICAL HEALTH
CARE AS WELL AS HI ACOSTA LIVE
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK IS DAY
AS MYSELF.
THAT IS IN NEED OF AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE WHICH JOB WE CAN
AFFORD BECAUSE THAT'S OUR
COMPANY PUT OUT A LOT OF THE
MEDICAL --
ASSURANCE OUT THERE THAT WE
CANNOT FOR WHICH WE HAVE TO PAY
85% OF IT AND THEY PAID A 15%.
AND A LOT OF US --
WELL WE HAVE A LOT OF EACH OTHER --
WORKERS THERE LESSEN YOUR
SEVENTIES OR LATE SEVENTIES I
WOULD LIKE TO BE TIRED AND CAN'T
RETIRE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO BECAUSE IT OFF.
THE HIGH COST OF LIVING IN THE
BAY AREA AND A WALK AROUND AN
EMPTY WILL CHOOSE TO USE INVEST
WALKERS.
BECAUSE A LOT OF PAIN HEY NAM
THEIR SUFFERING.
AND NATION WE STILL TRYING TO
FIGHT TO GET THIS UP THROUGH THE
UNION THIS WAS THE ALL WITH THE
COMPANY.
OF THE STATE OF THE GET MORE OFF
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE I WILL
GIVE A GOOD BARGAIN AND NEXT
TUESDAY.
AND THING I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT --
WE HOPE THAT --
THERE LIES IN THEIR CONTRACT.
DEAL WITH WITH THE STATE TRAVEL
PROGRAM DUE TO OF MOM YOU MORE
TO COMPLY WITH OUR LAWS AND
SUPPORT.
THE UNION JOBS IS SURE TO SAFETY
OF OUR WORKERS AND PASSENGERS
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HELLO EVERYONE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA ROMERO.
I WORK FOR A COMPANY CALLED AS
C. AS IN TERMINAL ONE LA X..
DOING SECURITY WORK A MONITOR
CAMERAS AND TO CROP INTRO.
IN OTHER TAX TO HELP SECURE THE
AIRPORT FOR SAFETY FOR THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE.
LAST YEAR'S STOP WEST AIRLINES
SWITCHED MY WORK.
IN THE WORK OF OTHER SECURITY
EMPLOYEE A COMPANY CALLED
GATEWAY TO A S. C. S..
WHICH IS NON UNION.
WENT SUFFERS SWITCHED US. TO A
CS ARE LOS ON MY HEALTH
INSURANCE.
IN MY COURSE LAST YEAR'S AWESOME.
NO I CAN AFFORD TO GET IN
[inaudible]
NEW GLASSES.
WHICH IS MORE DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO MOURN FOR THE SECURITY
CAMERAS.
MY WORK HOURS HAVE BEEN REDUCED
I LOST MY SENIORITY RIGHTS.
MOST IMPORTANT TO ME I DON'T
HAVE ANY.
JOB SECURITY.
I FEEL LIKE ANY GIVEN DAY I WILL.
WITH GATEWAY IN OUR UNION WE HAD
JOB SECURITY [inaudible]
WE HAD.
BETTER HEALTH BENEFITS YOU HAVE
MORE HOURS TO WORK.
WORK HOURS.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU.
THAT WE NEED. TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE TRAVEL PROGRAM WHICH IS
SPENDS MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS TO HELP --
HOLD STANDARDS FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS.
AIRLINES AND THEIR CONTRACTORS
WHO BENEFIT DIRECTLY FROM THE
STATE TRAVEL PROGRAM MUST DO
MORE TO COMPLY WITH OUR LOANS
SUPPORT GOOD UNION JOBS AND
ENSURE SAFETY FOR ALL WORKERS.
AND PASSENGERS THANK YOU.
YOUR NAME GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS BARBARA GOMEZ.
I'M.
JUST OKAY I'M HERE ALSO FROM LA
X..
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF I'M A CO
WORKERS --
I'VE BEEN WORKING AT THE LA X.
DOING.
EIGHT AGING CABINET IN FOR SIX
YEARS.
WITH A COMPANY CALLED G..
TWO AND SIX MONTHS AGO THIS --
THE AIRLINE AMERICAN AIRLINES
THAT BE.
OF WORK FOR SWITCH OVER TO A
COMPANY CALLED JET STREAM
[inaudible]
AND HONESTLY WITHIN SIX YEARS
WORKING FOR G. TWO AND SIX
MONTHS WORKING BUT THAT SHRINK.
MY BODY IS COMPLETELY
[inaudible]
THE FATHER --
ON BEHALF OF ALL THESE.
BEFORE THAT STREAM.
WE WERE WORKING FOR A COMPANY
LIKE ASSIST YOU.
TO WITH THE UNION. TO DREAM WE
DON'T HAVE NO UNION.
NO SUPPORT NO [inaudible]
PROTECTION.
I WORK FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
I HAVE TO CARRY ALMOST APPLIES
TO THE YEAR CROP.
I WALL FROM AIRCRAFT THE
AIRCRAFT.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
I WORK IN THE RAIN.
WALKING WITH SUPPLIES.
IN THE CALLS LATELY. ELEVEN
EXPERIENCING A LOT OF LITTLE
INNER.
WE HAVE NO PROTECTION WE WALKING
OUT.
IN THE MIDDLE ON THE AIR FOR THE
AIRFIELD.
ALL IN OPEN AIR HOLD
[inaudible]
RATE.
WAS CARRY ON BRENDA.
I'M HERE THE AXE. TWENTY UNION
PROTECTION.
UNLESS OF THE REALLY HURTS
YOU'RE GOOD --
A CAR CURRENT COMPANY THE TEAM
SEEMS LIKE.
WE ARE SLAVES ARE DOGS.
THEY TREAT US WITH NO RESPECT.
THEY ISOLATE THEIR HR FROM US.
WE CAN CONTACT THEM --
TALK TO NOBODY THEY GIVE US
WEBSITE THE GOLAN.
I WORK FOR SIX MONTHS WITH THEM
I HAVE NO PAYCHECKS THE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I'M GETTING PAY.
FOR THEY GIVE US THEY TOOK AWAY
OUR BENEFITS SO WITH SENIORITY.
YOU KNOW ITS --
THEY GAVE US MEDICAL.
SIGNATURE I HAVE NO CLUE I CALL
DIFFERENT DOCTORS WHO ACCEPT
SIGNATURE.
NOBODY IT YOU KNOW EXCEPT THIS
MEDICAL HERE.
I USED TO HAVE KAISER WITH G..
TO WHICH I COULD GO TO ALONE.
LET'S SEE A DOCTOR I'M GOING
ILLNESS A SMUGGLING TYPE THESE
[inaudible]
AND I'M.
HI TO PROTECT TO THEIR BETTY I'M
SIXTY ONE YEARS OLD.
BUT I HAVE NO SIX MONTHS NO
DOCTOR HOW THE SCENE.
LOAD UP THE WITHIN SIX MONTHS.
SO I'M HERE THE AXE [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO OUT.
EVERYBODY --
MY NAME IS OSCAR ANTONIA.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING AT THE
AIRPORT FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND WHEN I START WORKING AT
THEREFORE WITH THE AND HOW UNION.
SO WITHOUT WITHOUT ID'S WITH THE
THAN HAVA HEALTH INSURANCE.
WITHOUT PROTECTION [inaudible]
PHONE WHEN.
WHEN I HEAR YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
MONEY THEY WANT TO SPEND YOU
KNOW GIVEN TO THE AIRLINES I
MEAN?
IS THAT SIDE TO ME IN ALL LIVING
IN THIS COUNTRY [inaudible]
DODD.
IS THE AIRLINES THEY BUY LASIX
PURITY.
THEY VIOLATE THE SAFETY OUT
THERE.
AT THE AIRPORT.
AND IT MADE ME THINK A LIGHT AYE
BECAUSE ON THE THE WARRIOR ONLY
I'M ON MY WAY I'M ALL ABOUT MY
WORK A ON NOVEMBER FIRST A
TERMINAL.
THREE AND I'M THE ONE WHO HELPED
THE POLICE. TO PUT THE GUY DOWN.
IN IRAQ WAIT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THAT WERE DOCTORS LAWYERS PEOPLE
WITH MONEY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT TINY.
BEEN WE NEED THE WORKERS YOU
KNOW REALLY CAN HAVE A HEALTH
INSURANCE.
THEY CAN HAVE THE SAFETY
TRAINING.
THEY CAN HELP PROTECTION AT THE
JOB.
WORK AND THEY CAN BE ABLE.
ENOUGH TO RESPONDING EMERGENCY
BUT WE HAVE A COMPANY THAT ARE
RIGHT NOW.
THE THE RESPONSIBLE COMPANY THEY
DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT THE
PASSENGER.
YOU'VE GOT YOUR PASSENGER WE
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS EVERY DAY.
AND WE'LL HAVE THAT SAFETY
TRAINING FOR THESE PEOPLE.
WE ARE THE FRONTLINE.
BUT THEY LOOK ALSO SECOND PLUS
PEOPLE.
WILL NOT A SECOND CLASS PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE AND WE'RE
THEREFORE YOU MIGHT BE YOU.
IT MIGHT BE A NEXT TIME IT MIGHT
BE ME I GOT.
SEOUL WHEN I THINK OF ALL THIS
MONEY.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE THEY SAY ALL
THE UNION WE BARK WE MAKE NOISE.
YEAH BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE THE
PROTECTION.
WE HAVE A GOOD SYSTEM IN UNITED
STATES.
BUT WE DON'T REINFORCE THE
SYSTEM THOUGHT THE UNION WEARING
FOR THE FIFTH.
AND SEE IF THE CHEWING AND ALL I
WORRY ALLOW MY PEOPLE OUR ABOUT
THE THE PASSENGERS.
AND YOU SIDE THAT THE PASSENGER
BAIT FOR SECURITY.
THE PASSENGER BAY THE MONEY AT
THE AIRPORT.
EVEN YOU KNOW SAFETY.
NUMBER ONE FOR ME.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE A GOOD
WORKERS.
WE HAVE IT WE WILL ONLY OF THOSE
A RECEIPT RESPONSIBLE COMPANY.
AND THEY VIOLATE THE SYSTEM.
SPECIAL THE SAKE THIS COMPANY
THE EIGHT TALKING ABOUT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAFETY THREE
INCLUDES PEOPLE.
SAW HOW WE'RE GOING TO HOW
WORKERS.
THAT WE WORK IN THEIR A THEY'LL
KNOW HOW TO THE WING EMERGENCY
HE CAN BE YOU'LL YOU LIKE TO SAY
ANYBODY.
I MIGHT BE THERE I MIGHT BE ABLE
TO HELP BUT I'M DIFFERENT.
SEOUL I HOPE THIS COMMUNITY.
TODAY WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT
[inaudible]
WE NEED [inaudible]
RESPONSIBLE.
AIRLINES.
SO DUMB DUMB VIOLATE THE SYSTEM
A LIKE.
BY SENATOR THAT ALSO SAY WE WORK.
IN BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY.
BUT WILL THE WORKING ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY HERE.
THEIR PARTY THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN IS THE US ME NUMBER IS ZERO
TWO WELL?
ONE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS YOU
KNOW TO OUR SINGLE THIS MOVE
ANNUAL OF A UNDERLYING TO STAMP.
I'VE BEEN WORKING FOR NINETEEN
YEARS IN THE INDUSTRY.
THE PERCENT OF AMELIA'S THEIR
YOUNG HE TOLD YOU THAT THE
HUBBLE DISLIKING THE SAW THE
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING ON
THOUSANDS OF JANITORS AND
WORKERS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ESTO YEAH KEY UP FOR YOUNG
HONEST OF COMPANION OF THAT ARE
REQUIRED.
I'M HERE SUPPORT MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS FROM THE AIRPORT.
PHOTOS QUE THEY MOST.
GALA.
WEST OF GET BY THE MALL SAY ON
THAT'LL SELL IDLE I'LL SAY
LONELINESS.
BUT OKAY YES.
COOL RENTALS MANY PEOPLE'S LESS
MS.
OVER TO THEM IN THE CUP BY LAW
SIMPLY OTHERS.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
TAX DOLLARS GO TO AN OF HEALTH
AND WELFARE FOR FOR THEIR
WORKERS IN.
THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S BEEN ALMOST A POOR YOU'LL
EAT GALA NO SO YOU LIVE BY THE
CASE THE SIMPLEST TOOLS NO SO
YOU THEN UNLESS THIS COMPANION --
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO ASK YOU.
WE WE WE THANK YOU AND WE HOPE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE BENEFITS
ARE BEING EXTENDED TO WORKERS AT
THE AIRPORTS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WELL --
I THINK THAT LEADS TO A FEW
QUESTIONS.
ON THIS PROGRAM BUT I THINK IN
GENERAL.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
THE STATE THERE WERE CONTRACTING
OR SUBCONTRACTING WITH --
AND USING A TAXPAYER RESOURCES
TOWARDS --
COMPANIES THAT ARE NOT VIOLATING.
LABOR LAWS AND OR PROVIDING
LIVING WAGES.
THIS CERTAINLY MADAM CHAIR IT'S
A FAIR QUESTION AND AND JUST --
TO THE CARD IS IN A RECOGNIZE
THE THE STORIES OF CALIFORNIANS
OF REAL PEOPLE IN OUR STATE.
AND CERTAINLY THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING ALL OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE A LIVING WAGE AND I ACCESS
TO MEDICAL CARE AND ALL THE
THINGS SPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
OUT HARD WORKING THE TOUGH JOBS --
THAT WE ALL NEED HIM FOR I THINK
THAT'S CLEAR CLEAR POINT BY THE
WITNESSES AND SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THANKS --
WITH THAT I AM I THINK WE TO
SPEAK SPECIFIC TO THE PROGRAM AN
ITEM BEFORE US BUT ALSO BE
RESPECTFUL OF YOUR QUESTION.
OF KIND OF HIGHER LEVEL DETAILS
AROUND HOW WE CONTRACT --
AT THE STATE LEVEL SO MATT
BENDER HAS JOINED US FROM OUR
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE USE THAT KIND
OF THE EXPERT ON ALL THINGS
CONTRACTING --
SPECIFIC TO THE CONTRACT --
THAT I THINK IS MENTIONED BOTH
IN THE STAFF REPORT AND CLEARLY
SEVERAL IN A SPOKE.
TO LA ACTS AND SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES ARE THINK WE WE WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WE DO HAVE A
REALLY WHAT IS A SAVINGS
CONTRACTS THAT WE PUT OUT --
RECOGNIZING THAT THE STATE HAS
PURCHASING POWER AND SO --
WE GO OUT AND TRY TO FIND
AIRLINES WILL GIVE US THE
DISCOUNT AND SAVE AS MUCH MONEY
FOR THE STATE AS POSSIBLE ON THE
CONTRACT CURRENTLY THAT WE HAD
TO HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES WHO DOES
PROVIDE A DISCOUNT.
A DISCOUNTED FARE TO USERS.
AS A RESULT THAT CONTRACT
RESULTS IN ABOUT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN ANNUAL SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CONTRACT IS UP AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR IS THAT THE STAFF
REPORT ALSO POINTS OUT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DISCUSSING.
WHAT NEXT --
QUITE HONESTLY EVEN WITHOUT THAT
CONTRACT WERE STILL TRAVELING
RIGHT THIS TRAVELS HAVING A
STATE REGARDLESS OF THE CONTRACT
WERE TRYING TO MAXIMIZE VALUE
FOR THE STATE THROUGH THE
CONTRACT --
WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU AND AND ANY
OTHER INTERESTED PARTIES
INCLUDING --
MEMBERS OF SEATO IN THEIR
LEADERSHIP ABOUT HOW WE MAKE
THAT A RESPONSIBLE CONTRACT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE STAPLES HAS
THE AUTHORITY AND ABILITY TO DO
SO THROUGH OVERSIGHT --
BUT WITH THAT YOUR BROADER
QUESTION I THINK I'LL LET MATCH
I'M IN IT AND AND THAT'S YOUR
QUESTION REGARDING POSSIBLE CON.
IS OKAY --
MET BETTER DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES OF THE YOU KNOW THE THE
GENERAL REQUIREMENT THAT --
BETTER BE A RESPONSIBLE BETTER
IS --
CLICKABLE ACROSS ALL AREAS OF
PUBLIC CONTRACTING OF PUBLIC
WORKS GOOD SERVICES INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IN DETERMINING
WHETHER.
A BIDDERS ARE RESPONSIBLE BETTER
WERE GUIDED BY STATE LAW
INCLUDING --
NUMBER DECISIONS OVER THE YEARS
BY THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC WAGE AND
BENEFIT REQUIREMENTS FOR PEOPLE
WORKING --
FOR CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS TO THE STATE
THERE ARE TWO MAIN AREAS WHERE
THOSE ARE REGULATED --
THE ONE IS AND PUBLIC WORKS
WHERE TRAITS PEOPLE ARE SUBJECT
TO THE RAILING WAGE LAW.
THAT INCLUDES BOTH STATE
PROJECTS AND SOME STATES SPOT
STATE SPONSORED PROJECTS WERE
THE STATE IS.
EFFECTIVELY.
CAUSING THE PROJECT TO HAPPEN
AND JASON MAY BE IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
EXACT BOUNDARY CHASE MAY BE BLE
TO ADDRESS THOSE.
THE OTHER IS AND THE SPECIFICS
OF SERVICES.
CALLED OUT INSPECTION NINETEEN
ONE THIRTY FOR THE GOVERNMENT
CODE --
THOSE --
JANITORIAL HOUSEKEEPING SERVICES
CUSTODIANS FOOD SERVICE WORKERS
LAUNDRY WORKERS WINDOW CLEANERS.
AND SECURITY GUARD SERVICES AND
SORRY WHAT SECTION WAS --
NINETEEN ONE THIRTY FOR THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT.
OF SORRY MIKE.
GOVERNMENT CODE --
A HANDS.
WHEN WHEN THE STATE IS
CONTRACTING SPECIFICALLY FOR
THOSE SERVICES --
THE PROVISION THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY PROVIDE
EMPLOYEE WAGES AND BENEFITS.
THAT ARE VALUED AT AT LEAST 85%
OF THE STATE EMPLOYER COST PER
WAGES AND BENEFITS IN THE
COMPARABLE --
STATE JOB CLASSIFICATION --
WE CASUALLY GET THE COMPLAINTS
ABOUT --
THAT SOMEBODY ISN'T DOING THAT
IN -- AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE LOOK INTO
IT WE TALKED WITH THE CONTRACTOR
WE TALK WITH THE EMPLOYEES AND
WE DO OUR BEST TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON AND GET THE
CONTRACTOR IN COMPLIANCE IF
THEY'RE NOT [inaudible]
OKAY -- YOU
KNOW I I CAN APPRECIATE THAT --
LOOKING FOR THE VALUE AND USING
OUR CONSUMER POWER --
AND I KNOW THAT'S WHY I APPLAUD
THE PROGRAM AS WELL --
FOR DOING THAT --
AT THE SAME TIME --
IF THAT RESULT IF PART OF THAT
NOT DIRECTLY BUT IT ONE THING IS
FOR A COMPANY THEN TURNS AROUND.
AND DOESN'T PROVIDE THAT --
SO ALL THESE MEN AND WOMEN WHO I
TALKED ABOUT HAVING HAD MEDICAL
INSURANCE.
PRIOR TO A DIFFERENT COMPANY
COMING IN.
A BY THE END CONTACTED BY THE
AIRLINE OR HAVING OTHER --
VERY IMPORTANT THINGS IN THEIR
LIVES WAGES.
SO HERE WE ARE HELPING OUR YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT VALUE AS GREEN
IN OR SAVING US MONEY BUT THEN.
THOSE SAY MEN AND WOMEN MANY OF
THEM ARE GOING TO END UP HAVING
TO GET PUBLIC SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD.
OR THEN I GIVEN THE HEALTH
INSURANCE SO THINK ABOUT HOW
THAT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR
US SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THERE TAXPAYERS JUST
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
THAT THE VALUE SHOULD BE
BROADENED TO INCLUDE THE WELL
BEING OF THOSE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
PROVIDE THAT THE SERVICES SO --
I THINK WE'RE GONNA PULL THIS
OPEN CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION --
I APPRECIATE ALL THE GOOD WORK
OF THE TROUBLE PROGRAM I THINK
WE HAVE TO DO MUCH MORE IN THE
AREA OF WHETHER IT'S A DIRECT.
A COMPANY THAT WE'RE DOING
BUSINESS WITH OR SUBCONTRACTOR
OF THAT COMPANY.
SO THEY COULD GET OUT OF NOT
DOING OF WHAT THEY SHOULD I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO PAY
MORE ATTENTION.
TO HI THANK YOU SENATOR.
THE MORE THINGS --
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS OPEN --
OKAY CLICK ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY.
SO THAT NEXT ISSUE IS ISSUE
NUMBER --
NINE THIS IS OUR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE SERVICE OF WOMEN
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSESSMENT AND
FACILITY DEVELOPMENT REQUESTS --
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE THIRD YEAR
WE ARE BRINGING UP THE STUFF YOU
SEE PEOPLE THIS PROGRAM BEFORE --
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. TWO YEARS AGO
OR ASK. FOR THIS PROGRAM TO
INSTALL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR FLEET AND WORKPLACE
THROUGHOUT STATE FACILITIES THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS COMMITTEE
AT THAT TIME REQUESTED THAT
INSTEAD OF PROVING A FIVE YEAR
PLAN THEY WANT US --
TO BOTH MAKE TO ASK FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AND PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE PREVIOUS --
SUCCESSES OF THE PROGRAM AND
WHERE WERE KIND OF CHANGING AND
SHIFTING IT FOR CHANGING
SHIFTING SO THIS YEAR'S REQUEST
IS FOR A TOW --
ONE TIME AUGMENTATION OF
EIGHTEEN POINT SIX MILLION --
TO OUR SERVICE REVOLVING FUND
250% OF THAT IS GENERAL FUND
CASH AUTHORITY THE OTHER 50% IS
JUST AUTHORITY TO THE SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND --
TUNES --
SUPPORT THE INSTALLATION --
ZERO USING ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
WITH ME SAID NANCY AND WHOSE ARE
DRIFTING DIRECTOR OF THE
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAM WHO CAN
SPEAK IN DETAIL TO BOTH OF THE
WORK WE'VE DONE THUS FAR IN THE
WORK WE HAVE BEFORE US --
BUT WE'RE HAPPY AS MUCH AS YOU
LIKE THEM.
I'M SORRY ALEJO'S.
WE JUST HAD A COUPLE COMING
CONSISTENT WITH SOME F THE
COMMENTS WE MADE IN PAST YEARS
AS AS WAS MENTIONED THIS IS THE
THIRD YEAR THAT UP SIMILAR
PROPOSALS COME FORWARD --
MAINLY OR COMMENT CENTER AROUND
ON THAT THIS IS A RELATIVELY
AMBITIOUS --
GOAL AND THIS IS JUST FIRST THIS
IS FOR STATE THESE CHARGING
STATIONS --
AT STATE FACILITIES BOTH FOR
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS FOR STATE
VEHICLES --
SO THIS WITH THIS PLAN THIS FIVE
YEAR PLAN WOULD BE ABOUT NINETY
FOUR MILLION --
AND SUPPORT ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED CHARGING --
CHARGERS BASICALLY HI TO SERVE
THOSE KINDS OF VEHICLES BUT
REALLY THE GOALS ARE EVEN BEYOND
THAT AND SO THAT THE COST COULD
BE SOMEWHAT MORE THAN NOT.
AND SO WE JUST NOTED IN THE PAST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER GIVEN THAT THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS WEATHER --
IT WOULD LIKE TO SPEND GENERAL
FUND WHICH IS CERTAINLY AN
OPTION AND IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE OR OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES WHICH HAVE BEEN USED FOR
THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY IN THE
PAST FOR EXAMPLE --
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND ON THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
FUND THAT'S BEEN USED FOR THIS
TYPE OF ACTIVITY IN THE PAST THE
ALTERNATIVE.
AND RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM OF FUND SO
THERE ARE SOME OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES DEPENDING ON THE DECIDED
PRIORITIES WE JUST WANTED TO
POINT OUT FOR FOLKS [inaudible]
OKAY.
NO COMMENT OKAY CENTERS.
SANDERS MAN I IT JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION --
WE DO HAVE THE THE STATE'S GOAL
OF FIVE MILLION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ON THE ROADS BY TWENTY
THIRTY SO HOW DOES OUR PROGRAM
FIT INTO THAT.
SO AS YOU KNOW THAT IS A VERY
VERY AGGRESSIVE GOAL I THINK
THAT WITH THE STATE THAT AND THE
NUMBER THAT WE WILL BE
INSTALLING IS A MUCH SMALLER
PERCENTAGE OF THAT HOWEVER I
WOULD SAY THAT IT HAS.
A SIGNIFICANCE IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE LEADERSHIP
BY THE STATE AS WELL AS BEING AN
EXAMPLE --
SO WE WOULD BE ABLE THE
INFLUENCE INDUSTRY FOR INSTANCE --
TO IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY
ADOPTION IN TERMS OF EMPLOYEE
ADOPTION OF VEHICLES IT CETERA
BUT THE ACTUAL NUMBER THAT WE
WILL BE INSTALLING IS A MUCH
SMALLER PERCENTAGE OF THAT FIVE
MILLION.
SO -- CAN WE
GET SORT THAT IN FOR MORE
INFORMATION AS TO MORE
INFORMATION AS TO I KNOW IT'S
SMALL.
BUT IT WOULD BE NICE TO SEE WHAT
KIND OF INFLUENCE WE CAN HAVE
THE STREET --
IS OUR WAY OF YOU KNOW
DESCRIBING THAT MORE THAN WE'RE
JUST GOING TO HAVE INFLUENCE.
AT THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF CHARGERS
WE EXPECT INSTALL AND WITH THE
FIVE YEAR FUNDING IS.
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED BUT I'M JUST
SAYING IN COMPARISON TO WHAT WE
THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED IN THE
STATE CODE --
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO NEED THE
FIVE MILLION IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO SUPPLY THE STATE FLEET
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPLY A 100% OF
WHAT THE STATE FLEET NEEDS.
IN TERMS OF EMPLOYEE ADOPTION WE
ARE PROJECTING SOMEWHERE HIGHER
THAN 5% OUR NUMBERS ARE BASED ON
A 5% ADOPTION BUT WE'RE
EXPECTING IT COULD BE EVEN
HIGHER THAN THAT 5210% EVEN SO.
A IN TERMS OF JUST MEETING THE
STATE NEEDS IT COULD BE EVEN
DOUBLE THIS NUMBER [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE MORE COMMON THING.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THIS OPEN
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT --
I'M SORRY PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK HIM SANDERS THANK YOU
SENATOR OUT WILL MOVE INTO ISSUE.
TEN THIS IS OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ITEM --
HISTORICALLY IN THE BUDGET
CENTER NIELSEN I'M SURE KNOWS AS
WELL AS THE WE'VE HAD A CONTROL
SECTION SIX POINT ONE WHICH WAS
ALLOCATE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDS TO DIFFERENT APARTMENTS IT
DUE TO FOR ME.
PROJECTS --
THIS YEAR THE APPROACH YOU WITH
A REQUEST IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF FUNDS
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE DOING THE
SAME -- TO
DO SPECIFIC PROJECTS SO WE ARE
REQUESTING SIXTEEN MILLION --
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR AND GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURES ALREADY TO
ADDRESS --
FEW CRITICAL DEFERRED MEANS
PROJECTS INTERSTATE BUILDINGS --
WITH ME --
TO FOR THIS ONE I'VE JAMAL MANY
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR A
FACILITIES MANAGEMENT DIVISION
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OF CURRENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO AS THE
DEPARTMENT REFERENCE THIS IS
REALLY A PART OF A NUMBER
PROPOSAL THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PUTTING FORWARD THIS YEAR
REGARDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
DOLLARS WORTH OF THOSE PROPOSALS
ACROSS MORE THAN TWENTY
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS ARE
COMMENTS AS AN OFFICE ARE ARE
PRETTY CONSISTENT ACROSS THOSE
SO IT'S IN THE THINGS I'M.
GONNA MENTION --
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JOURNAL GENERAL SERVICES ALSO --
APPLY TO THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT
VETERANS DEPARTMENT WHICH I HEAR
ABOUT LATER ON TODAY AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE HURT BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE --
SO JUST A COUPLE THINGS I WANTED
TO POINT OUT --
AS WAS REFERENCE THIS IS WE'VE
PROVIDED SOME SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING IN THIS AREA IN THE PAST --
AS A STATE --
ACTUALLY ABOUT I THINK ONE POINT.
THREE REALLY SIGNIFICANT --
INVESTMENTS IN TRYING TO TACKLE
ARE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG --
BUT THEY'RE STILL QUITE A BIT OF
IDENTIFIED NEED ACROSS MANY
DEPARTMENTS.
WE HAVE REALLY TWO MAIN --
AREAS OF RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED
TO THESE PROPOSALS --
AND THE FIRST IS REALLY THAT --
THAT.
ESTHER I'LL BE ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE REPORT ON
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDERTAKEN
AND THE REASON FOR THAT OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT.
THIS YEAR'S APPROACH DIFFERS
FROM PAST YEARS APPROACHES WITH
THE CONTROL SECTION SO THIS YEAR
BASICALLY DEPARTMENTS ARE GONNA
BE PROVIDED WITH --
KIND OF A LUMP SUM AMOUNT AND
DEPARTMENTS WILL IDENTIFY THE
PROJECT THAT THEY'RE GONNA AND
UNDERTAKE SOME PROJECT SOME
DEPARTMENTS HAVE ALREADY
IDENTIFIED THOSE PROJECTS FOR
EXAMPLE TGS HAS IDENTIFIED SOME
PROJECT THAT THEY'RE EXPECTING
TO UNDERTAKE.
IDENTIFIED THOSE PROJECTS --
BUT EVEN IF THE DEPARTMENT HAVE
IDENTIFIED AS PROJECTS THE WAY
THAT THAT --
MECHANISM IS SET UP THEY COULD
MAKE CHANGES TO THOSE PROJECTS
SUBSEQUENTLY AND SO REALLY THIS
REPORTING LANGUAGE WOULD JUST
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE INFORMATION --
ON WHAT PROJECTS ARE ULTIMATELY
UNDER TO RIGHT WHICH PROJECTS
WERE UNDERTAKEN IN KIND OF TRACK
THAT I'M IN THAT WOULDN'T BE TOO
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT DEPARTMENTS
ARE CURRENTLY DOING WITH THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING
THAT THEY RECEIVED IN PAST YEARS
THEY'VE.
THEY'VE TRACKED WHAT PROJECT
THEY ULTIMATELY HAVE UNDERTAKEN.
REALLY THE SECOND ON MAJOR AREA
OF RECOMMENDATION FOR ASK IS
RELATED TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MAINTAINING OUR BUILDINGS
ON AN ONGOING BASIS BETTER.
SO I THEY MENTION WE'VE WE'VE
INVESTED QUITE A BIT OF STATE
FUNDING AND IN DIFFERENT
MAINTENANCE --
OVER THE YEARS AND WE STILL IN
MANY CASES HAVE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG --
AND THAT'S TRUE FOR EXAMPLE FOR
TGS -- SO IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
WHEN WE STARTED PROVIDING THEM
WITH FUNDS THE BACKLOG WAS
IDENTIFIED AT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION.
AND NOW IT'S TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE MILLION AND WE HAVE --
WE'VE GIVEN THEM TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION IN THAT TIME FRAME SO
THERE BACK LIKE IT'S CONTINUED
TO GROW EVEN WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL INFUSIONS OF FINES --
THAT POINTS TO POTENTIALLY --
MAYBE SOME CHALLENGES WITH THEIR
ON GOING MAINTENANCE PROGRAM
THAT MAYBE WE'RE NOT FINDING IT
SUFFICIENTLY OR MAYBE TERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES GOING ON THERE --
OR MAYBE WE'RE JUST NOT TRACKING
IT WELL THEY'RE THEY'RE PROBABLY
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT POSSIBLE --
POSSIBLE REASONS FOR THAT AND
AND TO KIND OF KEEP UP WITH
THEIR ON GOING MAINTENANCE.
AND SO WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THAT
BECAUSE WE REALLY THINK THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE HAVING TO PROVIDE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING
EVERY YEAR RIGHT THAT WE SHOULD.
PROVIDE FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG AND THEN WE SHOULD TRY
TO ENCOURAGE DEPARTMENT TO HAVE
BETTER MAINTENANCE POLICIES ON
AN ONGOING BASIS SO WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THIS BACKLOG.
ON SO PART OF THAT WE THINK IS
HAVING DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS THIS --
ONE REPORTED BUDGET HEARINGS
LIKE THIS ON ON WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIR BUILDINGS ARE MAINTAIN
SUFFICIENTLY ON AN ONGOING BASIS --
AND ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT IS
AGAIN SOME SOME SUPPLEMENT
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE REALLY IMPORTANT WHICH
WOULD HAVE THE DEPARTMENT REPORT.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE ONLINE
WHAT ITS BACKLOG AS AND IT TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT'S GROWN IN
THE INTERIM AT THAT POINT THEY
SHOULD HAVE.
MOM LIKELY SPENT THESE FUNDS AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY'RE BACK
LIKE HAS CONTINUED TO GROW WE
REQUIRE REPORT FROM THEM ON WHAT
THEIR PLAN IS NOW ON WHY IT'S
GROWN AND WHAT THEIR PLAN IS TO
ADDRESS IT --
BECAUSE WE REALLY DO YOU THINK
THAT -- BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET A
BETTER HANDLE ON HOW DO WE HAVE
BETTER ON GOING MAINTENANCE
PRACTICES --
ON AN ONGOING BASIS SO THAT'S
THAT THAT'S THE SUMMARY PLEASE
LET ME KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
QUICK FINAL.
JUMP BETTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT --
THE REPORTING STRUCTURE UNDER
THE EXPLAIN WHY NO DIFFERS FROM
THIS PARTICULAR APPROACH THIS
YEARAND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS --
OPEN TO FURTHER DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOW -- TO
BAKER AN EFFECTIVE IN TARGETED
REPORTING STRUCTURE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR STATEWIDE.
BATCH OF PROPOSALS.
OKAY.
SO I WHICH WE'RE TRYING ARE YOU
TRYING TO GET.
A ARE YOU TRYING TO GET TO A OF
MASTER LIST OF ALL THE DEFERRED.
MAINTENANCE.
BY DEPARTMENT AND THEN IN TOTAL
FOR THE STATE.
SO --
TYPICALLY THE PART THAT WITH AT
LEAST THE YEAH BUT IDEA OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET.
EXACTLY ALL OF THEM SO IT
ACTUALLY OVER IT IN RECENT YEARS --
DEPARTMENTS HAVE PUT TOGETHER A
LIST OF SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT
MAKE UP THEIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG SOMETIMES
IT'S TAKEN A SEVERAL MONTHS
AFTER THE BUDGETS BEEN
INTRODUCED --
TO TO HAVE THOSE WITH SOLIDIFIED
BUT THOSE LISTS EXIST --
AND SOMETIMES THEY'VE CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER TIME SO WE'VE
BEEN GETTING THOSE LESSONS I
THINK TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AND IF YOU LOOK ACROSS
DEPARTMENT SOMETIMES THEY'VE
GONE UP AND DOWN IN PROJECT THE
PHONE UP AND YOU'D EXPECT SOME
OF THAT BECAUSE YOUR BUILDING'S
AGING NEW THINGS COME UP.
IT IS THAT THE LEVEL OF CHANGES
OVER FROM YEAR TO YEAR HAVE BEEN --
HARD TO EXPLAIN I THINK OUR
RECOMMENDATION SO WE HAVE THAT --
IN MANY CASES THIS YEAR ALTHOUGH
NOT IN ALL CASES.
I THINK OUR WHAT WE WANT TO KNOW --
WHAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING IS
INFORMATION ON WHAT PROJECTS ARE
ULTIMATELY UNDERTAKEN WITH THESE
FUNDS BECAUSE?
OF BAG THE CURRENT APPROACH
WOULD NOT GUARANTEE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE ANY WAY
OF KNOWING WHICH SPECIFIC
PROJECTS ARE ULTIMATELY FUNDED
WITH THESE FUNDS AND IN SOME
CASES --
PLACE WITH PAST FINDING SOME OF
THE PROPOSED PROJECT NOT
NECESSARILY FOR FOR DJ
SPECIFICALLY BUT IN SOME CASES
THEY'VE BEEN VERY LARGE PROJECTS --
MANY YOU KNOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS --
INDIVIDUALLY SO SOME OF THEM
HAVE BEEN VERY LARGE I'M IN SOME
CASES DEPARTMENTS HAVE
CONSIDERED PROJECTS THAT
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE THINGS
THAT WE WOULD CONSIDER DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND SO WE THINK IT'S
JUST IMPORTANT TO HAVE SOME
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
WHAT'S GOING TO GO --
ME WHAT'S ALTERNATELY FIND IT
AND THAT THAT THAT ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY WILL BE HELPFUL AND
I'LL HELP IT'S JUST TRACK BETTER --
KIND OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THOSEBACKLOGS --
MEET AT NEAR FROM YEAR TO YEAR
THE PRACTICES IN BASIS.
OKAY -- JUST
TO JUST ONE QUESTION --
BABY USING YOUR DEPARTMENT --
THAT WOULD HELP US FOR ALL
DEPARTMENTS IS HOW WOULD YOU
PRIORITIZE A PROJECTS.
OR HOW HAE YOU PRIORITIZE THE
PROJECTS.
SO WE'VE WE'VE GONE THROUGH --
A GREAT DEAL OF CONSIDERATION
INTERNALLY AND THEN ALSO LIVED
IN OF THE PARTNERS --
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT EVEN IN
SOME INSTANCES HAVE WORKED
OUTSIDE OF AGING --
OUR DEPARTMENT WITH OTHER
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THEY WERE ON THE SAME PAGE
AND IF YOU IF YOU BEGIN TO LOOK
AT THE CATEGORY OF PROJECTS
THEY'RE ALL --
THEY'LL KIND OF FILE ON THE FIVE
GENERAL CATEGORIES --
WE'VE LISTED AT LEAST THREE IN
OUR ANALYSIS AND AND REALLY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT FAR LIFE AND
SAFETY ISSUES THE MOST IMMEDIATE
ONCE YOU HAVE TO DRESS RIGHT
AWAY.
THE ONE AND AFTER THAT YOU HAVE
CRITICAL ONES WHICH COULD LEAD
FIRED BY.
ANY OF THE INSPECTION SERVICES
OR THE ADMINISTRATION OR
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND
STATE AS WELL AS OUR TOP THREE
PRIORITIES AFTER THAT I MEAN.
IT REALLY KIND OF DEPENDS ON THE
EMERGENCIES THAT WERE RESPONDING
TO A REQUEST --
FROM OTHER THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IS MORE LIKE REAL.
IN ALMOST EMERGENCY IT IS FOR
THE AGE OF OUR BUILDINGS AND FOR
THE KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING BY SPACE IN THIS
PROPOSAL RETIREMENT ELEVATORS
AND PILOT AND SAFETY SYSTEMS.
THESE ARE THE MOST CRITICAL
SYSTEMS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
NOW WE NEED TO REPLACE
IMMEDIATELY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY OF DRIVEN IT.
WOULD TO PUBLIC.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
OKAY SO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IS TO APPROVE THE REQUESTED
FUNDING FOR THE DIFFERENT
MAINTENANCE.
ON THE TOP SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE RECORDING
RETRIEVED CHOIR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO NOTIFY
THE CHAIR.
OF THE JAIL BC PRIOR TO
ALLOCATING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING TO THE DEPARTMENTS.
I HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATOR DORADO YES.
CENTER NIELSEN NO.
SENATOR UMBERG YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER I'M
GONNA PASS ON TO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER KENNY WHO WILL HANDLE THE
CAP ALI ITEMS.
WELL.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME --
FOR ITEMS ELEVEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
RUN THROUGH THE ABUSE OR TREAT
THEM SEPARATELY HAVEN'T YOU LIKE
ME.
TO THEY'RE ALL FREE CAPPELLI
PROPOSALS ON THREE PUBLIC
PROJECTS --
WELL WE'RE GOING TO VOTE FOR
THEM OKAY ALL SEPARATELY BUT YOU
COULD DESCRIBE THEM.
TOGETHER.
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK IN VOTE.
FOR THEM SEPARATELY. TO DO EARLY
DESIGN PHASES WE ARE NOW --
ASKING FOR THE ACTUAL
CONSTRUCTION OR DEMOLITION FUNDS --
TO KNOCK DOWN THAT BUILDING --
THIS IS A SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD
COMPLEX THAT IS GROSSLY OVER
SIZED AT ABOUT. FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND GROW
SQUARE FEET --
RIGHT NOW THE PRINT PLAN
OCCUPIES --
A PERCENTAGE OF THAT --
AND OTHER ACTUALLY RELOCATING TO
LEASE SPACE --
AND IT'S ABOUT A 75% SPACE
REDUCTION TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
FOR HOW OVERSIZED FACILITY IS --
IT IS WELL PAST ITS USEFUL LIFE --
DILAPIDATED THE FOUNDATION IS
FAILING --
IT DOESN'T HAVE CENTRAL HEATING
THERE CAN'T BE REPURPOSE FOR
OTHER USES --
AND THE BUILDING AND THE SITE
ITSELF IS.
ON SITEYOU HAVE AS BEST AS LEAD
ARSENIC MERCURY --
GOT PETROLEUM PRODUCTS IN THE
DIRT --
THERE IS --
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS --
THAT NEED TO BE REMEDIATED --
WHEN THE PRINT THAT WAS ACTUALLY
ORIGINALLY CREATED WAS BACK WITH
THE STATE PRINTER ACTUALLY
PRINTED TEXT BOOKS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THEY LITERALLY
BOB TRANSPORTED THEM VIA TRAIN
ACROSS THE STATE? TO THE
RAILROAD SPUR LIKE ON THE
PROPERTY ITSELF IN THE THE
REMEDIATED IT'S AN ANTIQUE
ANTIQUATED --
FACILITY ITSELF --
WE WE WOULD WE NEED TO TAKE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND TONS
OF DIRT AND REMEDIATED TO
DISPOSE OF IT --
IT IS A CONTAMINATED SITE --
SO THIS PROJECT WILL BE
REQUESTING TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE FOR THE
ACTUAL DEMOLITION.
OF THE SECOND PROJECT BEFORE YOU
IS THE RICHARD BOULEVARD COMPLEX --
WE ARE REQUESTING --
ONE BILLION IN LEASE REVENUE
BOND FINANCING FOR DEVELOPMENT
OF A OF A COMPLEX A LITTLE TO
CONTACT FOR THIS PROJECT BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND THAT
UPDATED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AT
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST.
DIGITS COMMISSION INDEPENDENT
FIRM DO A LONG RANGE PLANNING
STUDY FOR SACRAMENTO OFFICE
SPACE --
THAT LONG RANGE PLANNING STUDY
IT IDENTIFY --
FOR SPACE ACT THERE WAS NOT
ENOUGH SPACE IN SACRAMENTO FOR
THE PROJECTED GROWTH OF STATE
EMPLOYEES --
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT OUT --
JUST IN PRACTICE EVERY DAY --
WE ARE SEEING THAT SACRAMENTO IS
IMPACTED LEASING PERSPECTIVE J.
L. L. WHICH IS A A NATIONAL REAL
ESTATE FIRM IS ADVISING CLIENTS
THAT THEY EXPECT RATESIN
SACRAMENTO TO GO BETWEEN 78%
ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS --
IN FACT WE ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING
LESSORS ATTEMPTING TO HIKE RATES
UP -- ONE
VERY LARGE LEASE IN SACRAMENTO --
AND DURING REGIONAL GLACIATIONS
A LESSOR --
WAS VERY INSISTENT ON A 30%
INCREASE OBVIOUSLY WE DIDN'T
GIVE THEM A 30% INCREASE --
BUT IT'S REFLECTIVE OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE MARKET.
IN SO -- IN
LIGHT OF THE LONG TERM PLANNING
SPACE NEEDS DIGEST PROPOSED IN
PREVIOUS YEARS THREE BUILDING
PROJECTS THIS IS THE THIRD OF
THOSE BUILDING PROJECTS THE
FINAL -- ONE
THE OTHER TWO BUILDING PROJECT
WILL BE COMPLETED IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BOTH ARE ON BUDGET AND AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE --
WE ARE ULTIMATELY LOOKING TO
LEVERAGE THESE BUILDINGS TO
ADDRESS OUR MOST EFFICIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WAS JUST
TESTIFIED THERE IS A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE --
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE ACROSS OUR
PORTFOLIO THAT SAME CONSULTANT
WHO DID THE PLANNING STUDY ALSO
CATALOGS --
WENT THROUGH DID ASSESSMENTS AND
EVALUATIONS ARE XIN SEES AND
THEN RANK THEM IN TERMS OF
SEVERUS AND MOST EFFICIENT
BUILDINGS --
UP WE CAME OVER THE SEQUENCING
PLAN AS WE BUILD THESE NEW
BUILDINGS WILL TAKE TENANTS FROM
THE MOST EFFICIENT SPACE PUT
THEM INTO THE NEW BUILDING'S.
RENOVATE THE SPACE BEHIND THEM
AND THEY TAKE TENANTS FROM THE
NEXT MOST EFFICIENT SPACE AND
PUT THEM IN THOSE BUILDINGS AND
RENOVATIONS TO ADDRESS OUR
DEFICIENCIES --
THIS IS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
AND INNOVATIVE WAY OF OF DOING
THAT --
THESE BUILDINGS ARE ALSO --
THIS ONE AND YOU ALSO --
BUT THE RESOURCES RENOVATION
THEY ARE PART OF A NEW BREED OF
STATE CONSTRUCTION THAT WE ARE
DOING SACRAMENTO THESE PROJECTS --
HAVE BOTH PROJECT LABOR AND
COMMITTEE WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS
THEY EMPHASIZE AGENCY
CONSOLIDATIONS WERE SING BETWEEN
FIFTEEN AND 30% REDUCTION IN
STATE BUT PRINT BY DOING THESE
PROJECTS --
WE ARE LOOKING AT WORKING
DEPARTMENTS FOR EFFICIENCY
PURPOSES SO --
DOCUMENT SCANNING --
ID CAN ACTUALLY I THINK --
THE BILLION MEASURES --
THEY'RE ALSO DESIGNED THESE
PROJECTS FOR FUTURE FLEXIBILITY
AND APARTMENT OF GROWTH AND WE
ALSO HAVE --
A PRETTY ROBUST IN A VERY UNIQUE
I THINK SMALL BUSINESS AND
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE.
MONITORING PROCESS AS PART OF
THESE PROJECTS.
AND THEN FINALLY --
OUR RESOURCES RENOVATION SO I
MENTIONED --
THAT STUDY THAT IN FIVE OR MOST
EFFICIENT BUILDINGS WELL THIS IS
NUMBER ONE ON THE LIST --
IT IS THE MOST EFFICIENT
BUILDING THE STATE OWNS --
WE ARE ASKING FOR A POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA TO RENOVATE THE
BUILDING.
THIS BUILDING WAS BUILT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR IT WAS
ORIGINALLY CALLED THE RETIREMENT
BUILDING AND IT WAS THE FIRST
MAJOR STATE OFFICE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTED BY.
THE STATE --
YEAH POST WAR ENVIRONMENT --
IT IS ALSO A HISTORIC BUILDING --
THE BUILDING IS IN NEED OF A ALL
BUILDING SYSTEMS MECHANICAL
PLUMBING ELECTRICAL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS NEED
TO BE REPLACED --
THERE ARE NUMEROUS FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES FOR THE BUILDING
INCLUDING.
THE NEED TO INSTALL FIRE
SPRINKLERS --
WE WILL NEED TO RENOVATE THE
THREE STORY A THREE SEVENTEEN
STORY STAIRS IN THE BUILDING FOR
EXITING FOR BUSES TO MEET CODE
AND CORRECT SEISMIC DEFICIENCIES.
IT'S COME A BAD THING TO HAVE
EXITING STAIRS HAVE SEISMIC
DEFICIENCIES --
THE PRECAST PANEL SKIN ON THE
BUILDING --
WOULD MOST LIKELY NOT --
WITH WITHSTAND AN EARTHQUAKE
MEANING YOU COULD ACTUALLY HAVE
CONCRETE PANELS FALL OFF THE
BUILDING A STAFF.
IS GREAT BECAUSE OF THE BENEFITS
SACRAMENTO --
ASBESTOS AND LEAD PAINT OR
PERVASIVE IN THE BUILDING THE
BUILDING IS NOT ADA COMPLIANT --
WE NEED TO OPERATE UP THE
CONTROL LIGHTING SYSTEMS AS WELL
IT NEEDS A NEW ROOF AND
ELEVATORS [inaudible]
THAT'LL.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT NOW.
WHO WAS EVER WALK INTO A
BUILDING LIKE THAT THE TENANTS
ARE VERY HAPPY AT THE PROSPECT
OF OF GOING TO THE NEW SPECS AND
HAVING THE BUILDING RENOVATED?
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ON
THE PROJECTS.
QUESTION BECAUSE TO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS
AS WAS NOTED BY THE DEPARTMENT --
A COUPLE OF THESE ARE JUST
BASICALLY CONTINUATIONS OF
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED PROJECTS AND
A CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE --
EXPECTED THE COST WOULD BE LAST
THEY WERE CONSIDERED PREVIOUSLY --
AND THEN THAT RESOURCES
RENOVATION AS WAS REFERENCED IS --
IS IDENTIFIED AS A AS A VERY
HIGH NEED IN SORT OF NEXT TO NOT
PLANNED SO AS LONG AS
LEGISLATURE CONTINUES TO BE.
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT PLAN
THAT'S PROBABLY THE NEXT LOGICAL
STEP FOR FOR YOU TO UNDERTAKE
I'M SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS.
THE CONCERT THE CONCERT.
I'M JUST SOMETHING RELATED TO
WHAT WE HAD TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR BIDDING
ON THE SELECTION OF SO --
I'LL USE THE THE THE RICHARD
BLOOM ARE COMPLEX SO.
THAT IS A DESIGN BUILD PROJECT --
SO -- WE
OPERATE UNDER PUBLIC CONTRCT
CODE. ONE OH ONE EIGHT SEVEN ONE
ZERO ONE EIGHT SEVEN ULTIMATELY
IT IS A TWO PART SOLICITATION
PROCESS SO WE WOULD --
PUT OUT A REQUEST FOR
QUALIFICATIONS ARE Q. --
WE GET --
RESPONSE WILL BETTER IT'S NOT
REALLY BETTER SUPPORTERS --
IT'S A GENERAL CONTRACTOR AN
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM PARTNERING.
WE THEN REVIEWS QUALIFICATIONS
EXTENSIVELY --
THINGS LIKE --
THE AND THE I. R. CERTIFICATIONS
THEIR PERFORMANCE RECORD THEIR
SAFETY RECORD REFERENCES --
WE SHORT LIST THOSE TEAMS --
TO THREE L. THEM GO THROUGH AND
AN ACTUAL INTERVIEW PROCESS.
WAS ABSOLUTE TRUST AND FIVE THEN
WE GO THROUGH THE INTERVIEW
PROCESS TO GET THEM DOWN TO
THREE TEAMS LOS THREE TEAMS THEN
COMPETE FOR THE PROJECT WE ISSUE
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA WHICH IS.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF PAGES
OF SPECIFICATIONS AS TO HOW THE
BUILDING TO FUNCTION --
THE FIT AND FEEL OF IT IN SOME
CASES LOOKS --
INCLUDED NOT AS A CONTRACTUAL
REQUIREMENTS PROVIDED ON THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT THE COMMITTEE
WORKFORCE AGREEMENT --
AND WEBER TERMS WE PRE
NEGOTIATED WITH A TRADE FOR
THOSE -- AND
THEN THE TEAM'S THEN SUBMITS --
PROPOSALS SO IF IMAGINE IF WE TO
MEET THESE --
CERTIFICATIONS AND STANDARDS
THEY THEN PRESENT A PROJECT THAT
MEETS ALL OF THAT --
WE EVALUATE IT BOTH FROM
EIGHTEEN PERSPECTIVE MEANING --
ABOUT THE ACTUAL PARTICIPANTS IN
THE PROJECT THE SUBCONTRACTORS
HOW THEY PERFORMED --
WE LOOK AT LABOR VIOLATIONS LOOK
AT A WHOLE NUMBER OF THINGS --
BOTH THE PRIME THE SUBCONTRACTOR
LEVEL -- WE
LOOK AT THEIR SMALL BUSINESS AND
DB PLAN --
IT'S THE ONE PROCURED METHOD WE
ACTUALLY MAKE HEM SUBMIT A
UTILIZATION PLAN --
WHICH IS KIND OF NICE --
WE LOOK AT THE TECHNICAL
SPECIFICATIONS OF THE BUILDING --
AND THEN WE GIVE THEM ONE SHOT
AT AN INTERVIEW IN ADDITION TO
THAT SCORING TO SELL US ON THE
BUILDING THE TECHNICAL SCORING
THE INTERVIEW SCORES ARE
COMBINED AND THE BEST OVERALL
VALUE TO THE STATE IS AWARDED.
OKAY THE VOTE OKAY SO IT'S NOT
THE LOWEST --
WITH WITH REGARD TO THIS
SPECIFIC PROJECT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE --
OTHER TENANTS I'M SORRY WITH THE
REGION'S BOULEVARD.
OFFICE IS GONNA BE OTHER TENANTS
YEAH SO WE ARE KEEN.
FURTHER --
YOU TALKING ABOUT --
LIKE NON STATE USE YES YES
ABSOLUTELY.
WE WILL HAVE --
PARKING GARAGE OR SURFACE
PARKING --
THAT WILL BE DONE THE DAY
PRIMARILY USE FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES AVAIL FOR NIGHTS AND
WEEKENDS USE AS WELL THE CITY IS
EXPANDING NORTHWARD THERE IS A
RAILYARDS BRALEY ARTS PROJECT
THAT WOULD BRING AND THE PARKING
LOT FOR NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS
REVENUE --
WE AS PART OF THESE PROJECTS --
DO BILL CHILD CARE OBLIGATED BY
LAW TO BUILD A CHILD CARE
FACILITY --
TO BRING THAT TO THE SITES AND
THEN FOOD SERVICE AND RETAIL AS
WELL.
OKAY.
JUST WANT TO INCLUDE IN THERE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WITCHES.
SUBCONTRACTORS OR OF CONTRACTORS --
TO LOOK ON THE ISSUES OF LABOR.
ALL VIOLATIONS AND OR WHAT.
YOU KNOW THE 885% --
COULD APPLY TO THEM AS WELL SO
YEAH I WANNA.
KNOW I DO THAT IT'S A GOOD POINT --
I I SHOULD SAY FOR THE RECORD --
ALL THE BUILDINGS THAT DIGESTER
BUILDING SACRAMENTO ARE STAFFED
BY BGS --
UNION EMPLOYEES I MEAN WHAT IS
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE STAFF
FOR CELL GALLAGHER MAINTENANCE
AND THINGS LIKE THAT --
FOR THE MOST PART THE ACTUAL
MAINTENANCE THE BUILDINGS THE
OPERATIONS ALL TEACHERS IN PLACE.
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO. ONE ONE
ONE LEVEL BELOW THAT NIGHT OF
CONTRACTORS WELL IT'S IT'S SINCE
OUR EMPLOYEES THERE'S NO THERE'S
NO TO CONTRACTING THAT WOULD
HAPPEN OKAY SO IT'S D. G. S.
STATE EMPLOYEES AUDITOR'S WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LIKE THE PARKING
THE RETAIL --
YES OTHER THE TENANTS SURE
CHARGER WHICH IS A FORM OF FOOT
SUBCONTRACT BY CEDAR SANK YES.
OKAY SO FAR WE HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT --
PROJECT.
RIGHT WE NEED --
TO TAKE ACTION ON SO THE FIRST --
THAT WE NEED TO VOTE ON IS.
MAINTENANCE I KNOW IT'S ITEM
ELEVEN THE STATE.
LAST HERE SINCE.
THE DIFFERENCE I AM.
ELEVEN THROUGH THIRTY OKAY.
YEAH THE DO WE NEED TO TAKE THE
SEPARATE VOTES ON YOU CAN DO
NOTHING SO ELEVEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN OKAY SO I NEED A VOTE.
TO ACT --
ELEVEN TWELVE AND THIRTEEN WELL
MOVE UP ISSUE ELEVEN TWELVE
THIRTEEN OKAY --
LOCAL SENATOR DORADO YES.
CENTER YELTSIN.
SENATOR UMBERG [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO -- AS YOU
MAY BE AWARE --
THE BUILDINGS THAT WERE
CURRENTLY IN IS GOING TO BE --
REPLACED.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE NEED TO
CONSTRUCT SWING SPACE --
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF THE FINANCE
CAPITALIST ALL ALL THE OCCUPANTS
OF THIS BUILDING --
THAT PROJECT IS CURRENTLY
BREAKING GROUND DESCRIBES SWING
SPACE I'M SURE AFTER OTHERS OF
COURSE SO --
IT OBVIOUSLY IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
DEMOLISH THE BUILDING WHEN
PEOPLE ARE IN ITS--
SO WE NEED TO CREATE A
FUNCTIONAL AND COULD ARGUE
TEMPORARY --
FOR THE OCCUPANTS THIS BUILDING
TO CONDUCT BUSINESS AND SO WILL
BE CONSTRUCTING A NEW BUILDING --
ON A LOT BETWEEN TENTH AND ON
STREET BETWEEN TEN AND ELEVEN
CONSTRUCTION HAS BEGUN HASN'T --
THAT WILL HAVE --
MEMBER SWEETS IT'LL HAVE --
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IT'LL
HAVE HE BUILDING THAT WILL
ESSENTIALLY SERVE AS THIS
CAPITAL ANNEX FOR YOU GUYS --
AND SO IT WILL SERVE AS SWING
SPACE IN THE SENSE THAT YOU WILL
SWING OUT OF THE ANNEX INTO THAT
BUILDING.
THE ANNEX WILL BE DEMOLISHED AND
RECONSTRUCTED AND THEN YOU'LL
SWING OTHER STATE OFFICE
BUILDING BACK INTO NEW THE
CONTRACT THE TAX.
WE'LL STILL BE ROOM.
FOR US IS TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO I
SHOULD HAVE.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY OUR PRICE FOR
THE FIRST.
I DON'T MEAN TO ROB BUT I GUESS
I AM GOING OF THE SOUL --
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO THIS MY
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE --
TO APPROVE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
SO I'M GONNA LEAVE AT NOON.
SO THOSE OF YOU WERE WHERE THE
RECOMMENDATION IF YOU WANT TO
TALK US OUT OF IT OR ANY OF THAT.
FEEL FREE --
TO BUT IF YOU'RE.
RECOMMENDATION OR YOU'RE
ADVOCACY IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION JUST A JUST A
HEADS UP.
SO.
YEAH.
THANK YOU --
SO I WOULD ARGUE THIS REALLY
REALLY FAST SO TAKE ME TIME BUT
THE THE ULTIMATE --
JUST IS THAT.
THERE'S A CHP PRESENTS KERR
EARLY BOB PROTECTIVE SERVICES --
FOR THE CAPITAL FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR THE
MEMBERS FROM PUBLIC HERE --
IT IS A AND IT'S IN THAT SEES
PEOPLE A SWEET THERE'S ABOUT
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET OF A
DISPATCH CENTER.
THAT IS THE MINIMUM FOR THE
BUILDING IT IS VERY VERY SMALL
UNFORTUNATELY TECHNICALLY --
THAT WOULD TRIGGER WHAT'S CALLED
ESSENTIAL SERVICES STANDARDS OF
SOCIAL SERVICES STANDARDS AND
BUILDING CODE --
THINK ABOUT FIRE STATIONS POLICE
STATIONS HOW PATROL OFFICES
THESE ARE --
BUILD MINI FORTRESS BUILT THINGS
THAT ARE MEANT TO NOT ONLY BE
ABLE TO FUNCTION BUT TO BE
PLACES OF SAFETY IN COMMAND AT
THE END OF A OF A OF A VERY
QUICK.
THE WAY OR FIRE THE WAY --
CODE READS IS THAT YOU CAN'T
HAVE A ESSENTIAL SERVICES
PORTION OF BUILDING YOU HAVE TO
HAVE AN ESSENTIAL SERVICES
BUILDING --
AND SO BY VIRTUE PUTTING SEIZE
BE DISPATCH AND BOTH EITHER THE
ANNEX OR THE SPRING SPACE
BUILDING.
WE WOULD HAVE TO BUILD BOTH
THOSE BUILDINGS TO THE STANDARDS
IT IS INCREDIBLY ONEROUS
STANDARDS --
IT WOULD INCREASE THE COST OF
EITHER OR BOTH PROJECT BETWEEN
THIRTY AND 50% IT WOULD DELAY
THE SCHEDULE CONSIDERABLY --
IT WOULD HAVE --
MASS IMPLICATIONS FOR STRUCTURAL
SYSTEMS --
FOR IT WOULD QUITE BALLISTIC
GLASS -- ALL
OF THESE --
ITEMS AND WORKING WITH C. H. P.
AND ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS --
FINANCE.
WE HAVE PUT FORWARD FOR THE BILL
LANGUAGE TWO EXAMS THE TWO
BUILDINGS FROM THAT SOCIAL
SERVICES STANDARDS SO THAT
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET
DOESN'T CREATE.
MASSIVE IMPLICATIONS FOR THOSE
TWO PROJECTS.
THE CONCERNS.
AND THE CONCERNS.
SOME OF THE MOVE ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR RAZA YES SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR AMBER.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR PJ THEN.
RIGHT MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIFTEEN
MILITARY DEPARTMENT [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING STILL
MOURNING.
WE'VE GOT TWENTY MORE MINUTES
THE SHERIN AND GLOBAL TO TALK
FAST DRUMMER YOU PROMISES WHAT
DO YOU I'M INCLINED TO APPROVE
THIS GRANT TALK ME OUT.
NO ONE TALKED OUT OF IT ALSO
OKAY.
BLAZON BLAZERS THROUGH HERE GAY
SHE FIFTEEN YES THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL REQUEST EIGHT POSITIONS
ONE POINT SEVEN SEVEN ONE POINT
SEVEN FOUR FOUR MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH A
HIGHLY CAPABLE PROGRAM TO EXPAND
OUR USE.
OF NATIONAL GUARD AIR AND GROUND
ASSETS AND SUPPORT WHILE FOR
RATIONS BEFORE NOW WE'RE IN THE
BUSINESS OF DOING THIS EVERY DAY.
I AND WE ABSOLUTELY NEED --
THE THE HEAD COUNT TO IT TO BE
ABLE TO MANAGE EFFICIENTLY
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THANK YOU QUESTION RESIDENT.
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS.
LOOK AT THIRDS.
NOPE OKAY TO HAVE A MOTION SO
MOVED.
SENATOR OTHER YES.
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR UMBERG.
GREAT ISSUE.
SIXTEEN IN THIS ISSUE WE REQUEST
SEVEN POSITIONS IN A ONE TIME.
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION WITH THE
CORRESPONDING FEDERAL MATCH FOR
A TOTAL OF ONE POINT ONE EIGHT
SEVEN MILLION.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADDRESS CRITICAL NEED FOR
INCREASED FACILITY MAINTENANCE
STAFFING AS WELL AS PROVIDE PER
SEVEN VEHICLES AND THE
APPLICABLE TOOLSETS.
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES FOUR
POINT. ONE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND GENERALFUND AS WELL AS
A CORRESPONDING FEDERAL MATCH ON
GOING.
DELTA IS THE VEHICLES.
YES.
SO THESE MAINTENANCE WORKERS ARE
THEY GOING TO BE STATE EMPLOYEES
YES IT WILL ALL RIGHT --
OKAY AS THEY'RE NOT MILITARY
THOUGH NOPE THEY'LL BE --
THEY'LL BE WELL THAT NO THEY'LL
BE ON STATE ACTIVE DUTY THEY'LL
BE A AYE AND THEY'LL BE PAID FOR
BY THE STATE.
THE BILL BE UNIFORM UNIFORMED
PERSONNEL ABSOLUTELY OKAY --
YEAH.
THAT WAS MY QUESTIONS OKAY.
WE HAVE MANY CONCERNS IN THIS IS
BASICALLY CONSISTENT WITH TRYING
TO BETTER MAINTAIN OUR BUILDINGS
ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND IT SEEMS
LIKE A REASONABLE APPROACH.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
DEMOCRATS KNOW A MOTION SO MOVED.
SENATOR ALSO YES SENATOR I'M
NIELSEN.
CENTER I'M BURKE. TWO SEVENTY IS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THIS
PROPOSALS WERE REQUEST ONE TIME
JOURNAL FOR APPROPRIATION OF
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR FISCAL
YEAR. NINETEEN TWENTY TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
OUR CURRENT BACKLOG IS ACTUALLY
GOING DOWN BACK LOOK REPAIRMAN
IS COMING DOWN.
IS IT APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION TO USED --
TO TO ADDRESS PRIORITIZE THE
BACKLOG REPAIRMAN IS PROJECTS WE
HAVE ON GOING.
THE QUESTION SO MOVED.
WELL XIN FILLED.
THEM.
OUR COMMENTS ARE IN LINE WITH
OUR PREVIOUS COMMENTS BY WHAT WE
PIECE THEM FOR THAT.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
OKAY.
AND YOUR WERE WITH THAT YES VERY
MUCH SO OKAY.
JUST MAKE NOTE THAT ON THE
PRIORITIZE LIST THAT WE PROVIDE
TO ALEJO --
ONE MILLION IS ALLOCATED
CURRENTLY --
FOR THE LOS ELEMENTOS BRANCH
WHICH WOULD BE RELEVANT SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY FOUR ABSOLUTELY.
NOT THAT I'M INTERESTED IN YEAH.
THAT'S A BIG PROJECT ROOF
PARKING LOT INTERIOR BIG DEAL SO.
WELL I'LL DEFER FOR ANOTHER DAY
IN IN IN IN A MEETING I AM
INTERESTED IN THAT PARTICULAR
PROJECT SO THAT WE CAN WE DON'T
NEED TO HAVE THE ENTIRE GROUP
HERE TO DISCUSS IT VERY WELL.
UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY SEE NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
SO MOVED.
SENATOR OTHER YES.
SENATOR NIELSEN SENATOR UMBERG.
THE FILING THEM I THINK YOU WANT
TO TALK ABOUT WORK FOR YEARS.
THIS I'VE BEEN I'M SORRY
MEDICARE THIS IS SOMETHING I AM
KEENLY INTERESTED IN AND IF I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE IT SHORT
SHRIFT IF THIS IF THIS HEARINGS
SO.
I'M SURE OF IF I COULD ASK THAT
WE TAKE THIS UP --
THAT MAYBE THE NEXT HEARING OR
SOME OF BUT LET ME LET ME
UNDERLINE ITS IMPORTANCE IN MY
INTEREST SO.
WE CAN DO MA'AM IS.
WE CAN TAKE IT OFF LINE AND AND
AND DO A SERIES OF MEETINGS IN
IN IN YOUR OFFICE.
AND CAN USE THAT WAY VERY
BRIEFLY ABOUT WHAT IT IS YES
MA'AM WE'RE THEN GOING TO OF
COURSE.
YEAH SO SO WORKFORCE IS A IS A
IS A A PROGRAM WHERE WITHIN THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY A HEAD HUNTING
FIRM INSIDE THE MILITARY
APARTMENT SEE TO CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE TAKE INDIVIDUAL
SOLDIERS INTERMENTS THAT ARE
UNEMPLOYED OR BETTER YET UNDER
EMPLOYED.
AND WE PUT THEM TOGETHER WITH A
STABLE OF BUSINESS PARTNERS WE
HAVE PROBABLY FIVE HUNDRED NOW.
AND WE MATCH THE APPROPRIATE
SOLDIER WITH THE APPROPRIATE JOB
AHEAD HOLD THEIR HAND THROUGH
THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE
DEVISE THIS WE ROLLED OUT TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE YOU KNOW
GOING EVERY YEAR --
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE THE RATE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE DEPARTMENTTODAY WHAT WE
ARE DOING NOW IS DRAMATICALLY
REDUCING THE RATE OF UNDER
EMPLOYMENT IN THE DEPARTMENT.
WORKING WITH PROGRAMS LIKE.
ENSURE THAT THAT NOT ONLY
SOURCES HAVE JOBS OF THEM HAVE A
JOB AT THE ALSO HAVE A WELL
PAYING JOB.
THAT -- THAT
MAKE SURE THAT THE THE COME TO
DRILL THAT THEY PARTICIPATE THAT
THEY ARE ARE ARE NATION'S WAS
OUR COMMUNITY --
WE BELIEVE THAT SOLDIER THAT HAS
A WELL PAID WELL PAYING JOB IS A
A HUGE READING IS BENEFIT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT UNEMPLOYED
SOLDIERS ARE A HUGE RATINGS TO
TRACTOR FOR THE ORGANIZATION.
IS FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT READINESS --
AND THAT'S THE ELEVATOR PITCH ON
THAT WONDERFUL SO QUICK SERVE A
BILINGUAL OWN ROLE SO QUICK
QUESTION DO YOU PRIORITIZE THIS
DISABLED THAT'S ABSOLUTELY SO WE
ONLY TAKE CARE OF FOLKS IN THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WILL TAKE
CARE OF EVERY VET AND SPOUSE
ACROSS THE ENTIRE --
ROBERT HOWEVER MY QUESTION IS DO
DISABLED VETS HAVE PRIORITY OVER
NON TO STOP PER SE NOW E
WOULDN'T BE LIKE CAL THAT WERE
YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE POINTER IF
WE EVER.
OUR DOORS OPEN EVERYBODY WE TAKE
EVERYBODY EQUALLY WHICH DO YOU
KEEP TRACK OF WHO ARE DISABLED
VETS ANOTHER I'M NOT SURE THAT
WE DO.
FIND OUT I DON'T THINK SO SO.
OKAY WELL THAT'LL BE A
CONVERSATION THE WILL HAVE
BECAUSE THAT THERE ARE BENEFITS
TO BUSINESSES.
WITH RESPECT TO EITHER OWNERSHIP
OR EMPLOYMENT DISABLED VETS AND
WOULD SEEM.
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING WORTH
WHILE TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE NO COMMENT [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO WERE --
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL ISSUES
THEN.
WE'RE NOT TAKING ACTION BUT I
JUST WANT --
TO ADD THAT I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
BEEN KNOCKING YOUR BY YEAR YES
MA'AM ON DATES YET AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT NO TO THIS IS NOT IN
THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THEM I'M NOT MAKING A PITCH HERE.
I DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THAT.
BUT IT'S BEEN FUNDED BY THE BY --
SINCE SUPPORT NOW FOR FOUR YEARS
FIVE YEARS ON YES I AM MAKING A
PITCH IS MATH I DO BELIEVE THAT
IT [inaudible]
I LOVE THAT YOU'RE DOING IT I
THINK IT'S REALLY WONDERFUL THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN IT UP AND IT SHOULD
BE A MISSION THAT YOU CAN COUNT
ON YEAR AFTER YEAR SO.
I THINK WE WILL WORK ON THAT
REMEMBER OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ONLY HAVE A FEW MORE ITEMS.
GET A MAN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THE MORNING SUN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
MICHAEL MCGEE THIS SYSTEM W.
SECRETARY FOR AT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS OF THE
ITEM ON YOUR AGENDA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
IS FOR AN AUGMENTATION TO FIND
EIGHT STAFF TO PROVIDE OUR
REACHED A VETERANS DEPENDENCE
AND MILITARY MEMBERS WHO ARE
SEPARATING FROM SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PROGRAM IS ONE WE CAN BE
VERY PROUD OF IT. TO SOME
PRESENTATIONS AND MILITARY BASES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA PROVIDING
INFORMATION AND ONE ON ONE
MEETINGS TO EDUCATE VETERANS ON
THEIR BENEFITS AND CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THEM.
CAL TAP PRESENTATIONS INCLUDE
PRESS REPRESENTATIVES FROM
HIGHER EDUCATION THE OFFICE OF
STUDENT AID AND RELIEF WORK FOR
WARRIORS.
CALLIE CHAR FOR STATE JOBS
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
AND THE LOCAL IT INNER AGENCY
NETWORK COORDINATORS --
BEEN VERY ACTIVE RECENTLY IN
STATEWIDE EMERGENCIES.
ALL OF THE FEEDBACK YES I I
DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT.
SENATOR UMBERG YES SIR WANTS TO
INTERRUPT. TO SUPPORT THIS BUT
IT BUT AGAIN.
I DON'T THINK YOU WANT TALK ME
OUT OF IT RIGHT NOW SIR ALL
RIGHT SO BUT THE WHAT IS THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN THIS
TRANSITIONAL PROGRAM IN THE
PROGRAM THAT WAS JUST DESCRIBED
LESS THAN FIVE MINUTES AGO.
I'M TOLD THEY ARE INVITED TO OUR
PRESENTATIONS MANY OF THEM ARE
MILITARY BASES FOR EXAMPLE OF
OUR TEAM GOES TO CAMP PENDLETON.
THEY PRESENT INFORMATION ON THE
VARIOUS BENEFITS TO THOSE WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN SEPARATING AND
STANDING IN CALIFORNIA --
WORK FOR WARRIORS AS A SEGMENT
SO THAT IF VETERANS ARE
INTERESTED IN --
A PRIVATE SECTOR JOB --
THEY CAN MEET WITH THEM AND
LISTEN TO THEM BUT THEY CAN ALSO
MEET WITH THEM IN THE AFTERNOON
ON A ONE ON ONE SESSION.
SAME WITH KELLY TO OUR OR OUR
STAFF IF OF THE FUTURE VETERAN
IS INTERESTED IN A STATE JOB
THEY CAN ME WITH WITH ONE OF OUR
FOLKS OR KELLY CHAR.
AND FIND OUT MORE ABOUT HOW THAT
PROCESS WORKS SO MOST OF THEM
ARE STILL IN THE MILITARY BUT
THERE WERE READY --
TO SEPARATE --
AND WORKFORCE HAS BEEN A PART OF
MANY OF OUR PRESENTATIONS OKAY
IT'S YOU HAVE A VERY SIMILAR
MISSION.
SEEMS LIKE IT'S OVERLAPPING IS
THAT RIGHT I KNOW SIR --
THERE WE HAVE A LOT MORE --
IN TERMS OF SERVICES AND
PRESENTATION AND INFORMATION FOR
EDUCATION BENEFITS FOR BUT
CALVET HOME LOANS --
ON VETERANS HOMES.
AND WE HELP.
HELP THEM FIND AND DIRECT THEM
TO THE THEIR COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICES SO THAT THEY CAN
SEEK AND OBTAIN BENEFITS --
AND ENCOURAGING THEM TO TO GET
AND SO SO OKAY SO THEY'RE A LOT
MORE.
YOU DO A LOT MORE I CAN'T THAT
DURING THE BRIDE RIGHT.
DO YOU HELP FOLKS FIND A JOB.
NOT DIRECTLY --
MOST OF OUR EXPERTISE IS IN THE
OTHER BENEFITS.
AND THE JOBS THAT WE CAN HELP
THEM FIND MORE DIRECTLY ARE WITH
THE STATE.
I WORK FOR WORRIES COMES IN IF
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN PRIVATE
SECTOR JOBS.
OKAY -- SO
IT YES I'M NOT COME TOGETHER NEW
BUT I'M.
I'VE BEEN OUT OF THIS BUSINESS
FOR A LONG TIME SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A I HATE THIS WORD.
BUT I USE IT A LOT OF SYNERGY.
BECAUSE YOU'RE.
AUDIENCE IS EITHER A SIMILAR --
IT'S LEASED A SIMILAR AUDIENCE
VETERANS NATIONAL GUARD.
SEEMS LIKE THAT.
THERE WOULD BE A BENEFIT IN
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
COMPLETE COORDINATION DOES THAT
STRIKE YOU AS USEFUL --
YES SIR I THINK OF WHAT WE TRY
TO DO AS BEST WE CAN IS
COORDINATE WITH THEM AND THAT'S
WHY THEY'RE INCLUDED IN OUR
RIGHT PRESENTATIONS.
IN IT AND LIGHTING THE SHOW UP
WHAT I MEA IS THAT HAVING AN
INTEGRATED.
PROJECT.
JOIN THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT
VETERANS BECAUSE EVERY VETERAN
WAS IN THE MILITARY.
SO.
AND AM I MIGHT BE MISSING
SOMETHING BUT IT BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE.
THAT WE COULD.
CREATE SOME EFFICIENCIES I'M
GONNA VOTE I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
THIS BUT IT SEEMED MAY WE COME
BACK AND TALK.
WITH EACH OF YOU ABOUT HOW WE
COULD CREATE SOME EFFICIENCIES.
IN TRYING TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES. TO FOLKS
LEAVING THE YOU'RE LEAVING THE
MILITARY.
YOU WANT A JOB YOU'RE GOING TO
HELP WITH STATE JOBS RIGHT.
JOBS BUT A PERSON LEAVING THE
MILITARY.
JUST ONCE A JOB.
RIGHT.
YES BUT MANY OF OUR THE VETERANS
AND AND THOSE IN THE MILITARY
ARE INTERESTED IN EDUCATION
BENEFITS NO I GOT THE GUY KIND
OF THING RIGHT THAT AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT THEY'RE ONLY
INTENTION.
IT WILL LEAVE THIS DAY WILL BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL IMMIGRATION ALL EAT
TOGETHER YEAH.
RIGHT OKAY THANKS USER.
JUST JUST ONE MORE QUESTION --
HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE OF?
HOW'S THE PROGRAM PRIORITIZING.
TARGETED DEMOGRAPHICS OF THOSE
TO BE BEST SERVED THOSE ARE OR
MAYBE THOSE MOST IN NEED TO
PRIORITIZE AND ANYWAY.
WELL WAY --
LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
COUNTIES IN THE LOCATIONS THE
THE LINKS HELP WITH THAT BY
BEING ON THE GROUND IN THOSE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS --
DOING RESEARCH TO FIND OUT THE
TYPE OF VETERAN THAT IS LIKELY
TO BE THE IN THAT AREA --
IN CERTAIN AREAS.
THERE MIGHT BE MORE OF AN
INTEREST AND VETERANS HOMES --
AND GETTING A CALVIN HOME LOANS
AND IN OTHER AREAS.
PARTICULARLY WHEN THERE'S A LOT
OF YOUNGER VETERANS --
THE HIGHER EDUCATION BENEFITS SO
OF THE EMPHASIS USUALLY COMES.
MOVE IN THE PRESENTATIONS BUT
ALSO IN THE ONE ON ONE SESSIONS
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE PROGRAM
I THINK --
DOES ITS BEST WORK SO WE'LL WE
HAVE A GENERAL PRESENTATION AND
THEY THEY MAKE APPOINTMENTS
AFTERWARDS AND MEET ONE ON ONE
TO TO TALK WITH THE CVS SO ARE
OTHER MEMBERS WHO PRESENTED.
ON THERE'S INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND
I'VE SEEN THAT PERSONALLY SO IT
IT HELPS TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL WANTS TO
KNOW SO THEY TEND TO GET GET
TAILORED BY SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AND THE PRE RESEARCH
WE DO GOING INTO THE?
EVENT -- BUT
A LOT OF THAT IS DONE IN THE ONE
ON ONE SESSIONS.
ANY MORE QUESTIONS NOT. FOR
TODAY SO WE'LL.
WITH CENTER NUMBER FOLLOW UP YES
YEAH WITH HIS WITH THE ISSUES I
THINK THE REALLY GREAT IDEAS.
OKAY.
ALEJO'S.
JACKIE BRISTOW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE REYES NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
NOTE FOR THE LEGISLATURE IS ON
WHEN THIS PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY
CREATED IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO SOME WORK TO
IDENTIFY TARGET POPULATIONS AS
YOU'RE REFERENCING AND THEY
PARTICULAR IDENTIFY --
TO ACTIVE DUTY SERVICEMEMBERS OF
TRANSITIONING OUT I'M RETURNING
BACK TO CIVILIAN LIFE AND
STUDENT VETERANS SO THEY'RE
CURRENTLY I'M SURVEYING AND
DOING THESE PRESENTATIONS AT
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS --
CAPTURING THAT ACTIVE DUTY --
MEMBER POPULATION IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS REALLY THAN TAKING
IT TO THE NEXT STEP TO TARGET
AND DO SERVICE DELIVERY FOR THE
SECOND IDENTIFIED POPULATION
PROCESS WHICH IS STUDENT
VETERANS.
SO QUESTION THAT WE WOULD RAISE
IN GENERAL IS MORE OF THIS LONG
TERM PLAN TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY OTHER TARGET
POPULATIONS WHAT WITH THOSE LOOK
LIKE -- HOW
WOULD THEY EXPAND THEIR SERVICE
DELIVERY TO TARGET THOSE
POPULATIONS AND WHERE --
WHAT ACCESS POINTS WITH A
PARTICULARLY BE LOOKING AT AND
THEN ALSO JUST BROADER QUESTIONS
ABOUT LEVEL OF SERVICES WHILE
NOT ONLY WITHIN THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BUT BROADER? TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT THIS LONG TERM PLAN DOES.
HAPPEN.
SO HOW DO WE FOLLOW UP ON THAT
[inaudible]
RECOMMENDATION.
JENNY ABOUT THE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WHEN YOU YOU COULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO TO RESPOND ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW
OUR WHAT WOULD BE YOUR LONG TERM
PLAN.
AND THEN YOU ADD TO THE SENATORS
REQUEST TO HAVE SOME OF THESE
MORE IN DEPTH CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT OVERLAP BUT ALSO SERVICE
DELIVERY.
SO WE COULD WE COULD WRAP THAT
INTO INTO THAT MEETING AS WELL.
OKAY GREAT [inaudible]
ANY COMMENTS.
OKAY I'M JOHN SPANGLER
LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY FOR CALVET.
HAPPY TO ARRANGE A FOLLOW ON
MEETING TO TALK ABOUT.
THERE WERE BLOOD NUMBER BROAD
ISSUE QUESTIONS RAISED TODAY
APPRECIATE SUPPORT OF THIS PART
IN PARTICULAR BUT ALSO HAPPY TO
SET UP WHATEVER.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TO TRY AND
FIND OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WHERE WE'RE
GOING [inaudible]
AND BE GREAT IF WE COULD DO SOME
OF THOSE TOGETHER BETWEEN CALVET
AND THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT TO
MAKE IT EFFICIENT ABSOLUTELY SIR
THAT MAKES SENSE THANK YOU.
AND THE COMMENTS OR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IF YOU CAN TO US
AS WELL.
GREAT.
OKAY -- THE
PUBLIC.
IS THAT IT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT SO WE NEED A BOTH BOTH.
SENATOR RAWSON YES.
SENATOR NIELSEN CENTER I'M BURKE
YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES SIR SO I'M HERE.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS REGARDING
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY
WATER SYSTEM UPGRADE --
WE ARE ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL
NINE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS --
TO ADDRESS THE BUILDING CODE
FIRE CODE CHANGES WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE THAT THAT WILL --
BRING THE ENTIRE PIECE OF
PROPERTY UP TO CURRENT STANDARDS.
CURRENT FIRE CODE --
THE ORIGINAL PROJECT STARTED
WITH INSTALLATION OF SPRINKLERS
THEN THE MEMORIAL BUILDING THE
CHANGING CODE IS NOW OBLIGATED
US TO INCREASE THAT WATER
PRESSURE NOT JUST --
WITHIN THE MEMORIAL BUILDING BUT
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING --
MAINTENANCE BUILDING AS WELL AS
PRESSURE ON THE ENTIRE PIECE OF
PROPERTY.
OKAY QUESTION SINCE CERTAIN I I
NOTED THAT THE BUILDING WAS
DONATED IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S
CORRECT WHAT WHAT WOULD HAVE
COST IF WE HADN'T HAD THIS
BUILDING DONATED TO YOU KNOW.
SO THE DONATION --
THE THE SENATOR THAT THAT
DONATED THE KNOWLEDGE --
TO MAYBE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT DOESN'T RECOGNIZE
DONE -- A
BUILDING SUCH AS THAT.
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE
TEN TO TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
OKAY SO WE ARE THAT THAT'S THE
YES CRUX OF MY QUESTION ARE WE
ARE WE ARE NET BETTER OFF.
WE ARE EVEN THOUGH WE'VE GOT TO
GO BACK HERE AND DO A BUNCH OF
REMEDIATION WRECKED A COUPLE OF
THE OTHER THINGS IS IS THAT
WITHIN THE READING AREA I GO IN
PARTICULAR.
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
WILDFIRES --
THAT HAVE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
CLOSE TO THIS PIECE OF PROPERTY --
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THAT
MORRELL BUILDING WAS THERE ARE
NOT WE MIGHT HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
OBLIGATED TO JUST INCREASE THE
PRESSURE ON THE PROPERTY ITSELF --
JUST BECAUSE OF THE INHERENT
RISKS THAT ARE THERE.
OKAY AND THEN JUST A PLACEHOLDER
ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS CEMETERY.
SO THE ONLY TO RESPOND IT'S A
PLACE HOLDER FAIR ENOUGH OKAY.
PLENTY OF RESPONSES.
FOR YEAH THE TIME THE LEADER HE
CAN.
THE LATER OKAY RIGHT FOR LIKE --
I'M ALSO HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS REGARDING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IF YOU WANT TO GO
OUT A LINE.
WELL LET'S DO THIS [inaudible]
MALES CONCERNS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
OKAY [inaudible]
MOVED.
SENATOR DRAW THE SENDER NIELSEN.
S. SENATOR AMBER. FIVE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
SO -- ISSUE
OVER TWENTY TWO WHICH IS THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
REQUEST FOR THE DEPARTMENT WE
ARE REQUESTING FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS DO WE SKIP.
WE DID YEAH.
THAT'S FINE I WOULD JUST HAVE TO
COME BACK UP HERE THAT'S ALL
OKAY EXCITES YOUR ACTION AND
MA'AM.
I GOT ALL RIGHT GO HEAD.
ON THIS SO THIS IS A A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST --
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AT
PRIMARILY THE YOUNG BILL
VETERANS HOME --
THE LIST OF PROJECTS THAT WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOUR THREE
TOTALS THE COST OF FIVE TWO
RECTORIES OF WAR AS WELL AS THE
MEDIA WITHIN THE WATER TREATMENT
PLANT IN THE WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS PROVIDES DRINKING WATER.
TO THE HOME AS WELL AS THE TOWN
ITSELF.
YES WHAT IS IT WHAT IT SAYS
MEDIA WHAT IS MEDIA IS SIMILAR
TO RESERVOIR YES SIMILAR TO A A
SWIMMING POOL WITH DIATOMACEOUS
EARTH IT'S IT'S WITHIN THE
TREATMENT PLANT IT'S THE SYSTEM
THAT CLICK CLARIFIES PURIFIES
THE WATER WE WE IN.
PUBLIC LIFE HAVE A DIFFERENT
DEFINITION FOR MEDIA SURE THAT
SO.
THIS IS A MEDIA IS RELATES TO A
WATER TREATMENT FACILITIES
CORRECT DOESN'T NCLUDE PUBLIC
RELATIONS NOW IT DOES NOT GET
GOT ALL RIGHT.
SOME GOOD PICKS YEAH OKAY.
AND THIS WAS --
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
ALREADY.
SO NGUYEN USED THAT'S CORRECT
OVER THE PAST HANDFUL OF YEARS --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PROJECTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN PUT FORWARD --
IF ANYONE IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
YOUNG BILL VETERANS HELMETS IS
EXTREMELY OLDER BUILDINGS ARE
ARE IN SOMEWHAT OF DISREPAIR AND
WE'RE SPENDING EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNTS OF MONEY TRYING TO TO
KEEP IT UP AND GOING --
AT THIS POINT --
WE WOULD SAY THAT THE ELEVATOR
MODERNIZATION IS OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY THERE FREQUENTLY GOING
DOWN WE HAVE WE HAVE TWENTY SIX
ELEVATORS ON THE PROPERTY AND AT
ANY GIVEN TIME THERE IS A
MAINTENANCE --
INDIVIDUAL OUT THERE REPAIRING
AND A BIT OF EIGHT TO FIVE AND
CONTINUALLY WORK ON OUR
ELEVATORS THIS WILL MODERNIZE
THEM BRING THEM UP TO CURRENT
CODE SO THAT.
THE GUTS OF THE ELEVATORS WILL
ACTUALLY BE BRAND NEW.
SO MOVED MOST OKAY GOOD OF A
PROJECTIONS.
WITH.
NO CONCERNS WOULD JUST REITERATE
OUR PUT THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE MADE ABOUT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND INCREASING
OVERSIGHT FOR THE TO ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION.
SENATOR DRAWS YES SENATOR
NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG JUST. ONE LOWER
OR TWO MORE.
THANK YOU TAKE.
BACK TO TWENTY ONE OKAY.
ALLEN'S AS DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES FOR
VETERANS AFFAIRS WE ARE
REQUESTING A AUGMENTATION OF
HUNDRED AND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
ONGOING POSITIONS FOR THIS.
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN AND TWENTY
AND SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND ON GOING THERE AFTER.
FOR THE A PROGRAM REVIEW AND ON
ITS UNIT.
AND THIS WILL PROVIDE FOR
STANDARDIZATION --
EFFICIENCIES.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURE
COMPLIANCE SCISSORS AND JUST
TIGHTENING UP OUR INTERNAL
CONTROLS.
AND IT'S CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES.
READY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MEASURE --
IF TAKEN CORRECTIVE ACTIONS ON
THE NUMBER [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OF IN RESPONSE TO THE AUDITS OF
THE VETERANS HOMES AND THE
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAMS.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT.
WHAT YOU DID OR WHAT HAS THAT
RESULTED IN --
EVEN SHOULD GO HEAD.
HI MY NAME'S THOMAS MARTIN I'M
THE DIRECTOR FUTURE OPERATIONS
AND PLANNING FOR THE VETERANS
HOMES -- SO
AT SO SPEAKING TO THE AND THE
THE THE LEASE I KNOW YOU'RE
SHORT ON TIME SO CUT ME OFF
WHENEVER --
I WE HAVE MADE A NUMBER OF OF
CHANGES TO OUR PROGRAMMING --
WE'VE IN PAST YEARS WE'VE BEEN
REVISING NUMBER OF LEASES
RENEGOTIATING THEM IMPROVING THE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS.
IN RESPONSE TO THE THE REPORT
ITSELF WE'VE DEALT NEW POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES FOR SENATE STORY
UP TO HEADQUARTERS TO MAKE SURE.
ANY DECISION MADE ON ON PROPERTY
THE STATUE WITH.
I'M WITH ANY REQUIREMENT THAT WE
HAVE -- TO
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT GOING BACK
TO OUR OUR RESIDENTS THAT'S
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE HERE.
FOR SO WE WE HAVE MADE A NUMBER
OF OF FIXES IN THAT REGARD I
THINK THE THE THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING.
AN INTERNAL AUDITS --
UNIT IS THAT WE WOULDN'T --
WE WOULDN'T STRUGGLE WHICH WE
HAVE BEEN DOING WITH TRYING TO
IMPROVE IT PIECEMEAL AS WE GO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT LEASES JOBS
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY EXPERTS
OURSELVES --
AND INSTEAD WE COULD HAVE UNIT
WHOSE WHOSE SOLE PURPOSE IS
DEDICATED. TO TO DOING THAT KIND
OF RESEARCH A REVIEW SO THAT --
WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
FORMAL AUDIT TOO TO BE ABLE TO
DIG INTO SOME THESE CONCERNS ARE
SO IDEALLY WE'D BE.
WE'D BE APPROACHING THIS HEAD ON
WE BE ADDRESSING THIS DIRECTLY --
AND WE THERE WOULD BE A LAG
BETWEEN A COMPLIANCE PROBLEM AND
OUR ABILITY TO ADDRESS.
AND THE THE THE DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS AND A PRICE
OKAY -- HAS
FIRMS.
ONE CERTIFIED FIRMS RECEIVED 89%
OF THE CONTRACTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU A
GERMAN --
MADAM CHAIR --
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY YES SO --
I AM THE DEPUTY SECRETARY OF THE
pMINORITY IN UNDER REPRESENTED
VETERANS A DIVISION AND ALSO I
OVERSEE THE STATE.
DVD PROGRAM AS OF JULY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TO ADD TO YOUR
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO THAT
POINT.
THAT WAS FOUND IN THE AUDIT.
I YES WE DO IT KNOWLEDGE THAT AT
CAL THAT AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE SOME THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TOWARDS ON THAT
IMPROVEMENT IN HARMONY WITH THE
TGS.
AND SINCE THAT ACTUALLY BEFORE
SINCE BEFORE I JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND BOTH WHILE THE
AUDIT WAS BEING CONDUCTED.
AND WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS A
STEPS IN VARIOUS WAYS ONE OF
THOSE STEPS IS --
DISSOLVING THE INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT THAT WE HAD MORE
TOWARDS THE MILITARY VETERANS
CODE AND THAT OUTLINES OUR
DUTIES THERE IN REGARDS TO
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS.
AND ALSO INCREASE YOUR NUMBERS A
DVD MAKING SURE THOSE TV'S ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
I AT THAT TIME BEFORE THIS DATE
WE WERE MORE IN LINE WITH.
WHAT D. G. S. WAS DOING THE
WASN'T WE WEREN'T SO MUCH
FOLLOWING THAT --
THAT GO TO THERE ARE SOME
CONFUSION WHICH OUT WITH STATE
AND THE AUDIT AS WELL.
SOME QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF YOUR
OWN INTERNAL AUDIT AND WITH
RESPECT TO LEASES AND SO FORTH.
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S OVERLAP WITH
THE GS IS THAT RIGHT.
I I USED FOR INTO MEETING --
BRENT RUNNING LEASES LIKE
MANAGING YOU SAID THAT.
INTERNALLY YOU WANT TO BE ABLE
TO IN ESSENCE --
I I SUPPOSE MANAGE LEASES AN
AUDIT IS THAT RIGHT WELL WE WE
CURRENTLY ALREADY --
I I GUESS LET ME TAKE A STEP
BACK SO SO THE DEPARTMENT CHEN
SERVICES HAS HAS AUTHORITY
APPROVAL THIRTY ULTIMATELY FOR
ALL LEASES --
OF OF STATE PROPERTY I'M SURE
THERE'S SOME EXCEPTIONS BUT FOR
ALL OF OUR OF A LEASES --
DONE PROBABLY GO THROUGH THE GST
GET APPROVED BY TGS --
AND SO THERE'S THEY HAVE WHO WHO
PROVEN BUT I'M.
IT'S IT'S A COME UPON US TO
ACTUALLY OPERATE THEM SO EIGHT
YOU KNOW DID YES ISN'T
NECESSARILY AT THE OFFER
VETERANS HOME FOR EXAMPLE.
WITH MANAGING LEASES MANAGING
RELATIONS WITH --
WITH LESSEES MAKING SURE THE
COMPLYING WITH TERMS OF LEASES
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS --
SO WE'RE STILL WE STOP HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT THERE
ARE ALSO OTHER SPACES IS ARE
OVERLAP BETWEEN D. G. S. AND YOU
WITH RESPECT TO MANAGING LEASES.
YES CORRECT OKAY.
SO I'LL LEAVE THIS AGAIN FOR
ANOTHER DAY.
IT IT IT IT SEEMS LIKE TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S OVERLAPPING
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT.
JUST ORGANIZATIONALLY THAT'S
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE BECAUSE WHEN
YOU HAVE OVERLAPPING
RESPONSIBILITIES EITHER YOU'VE
GOT.
A LOT OF FOLKS INVOLVED OR YOU
GOT NOBODY INVOLVES SO I'LL
LEAVE IT FOR ANOTHER DAY AS TO
HOW.
CALVET BGS ARE GOING TO DIVIDE
UP RESPONSIBILITIES.
THE OTHER.
IT'S A QUESTION WITH RESPECT
I'VE READ BOTH THE AUDITS I JUST
READ THE DVB AUDITS.
IT'S IT'S SO INTERESTING --
SO IS ANYBODY THERE EVER TRY TO
ASK A QUESTION.
BY PRETENDING THERE A DV B. E.
BECAUSE I'VE DONE THIS WITH THE
DMV OF DONE THIS WITH.
AL THAT I'VE DONE THIS WITH THE
GS WERE JOHN Q. CITIZEN CALLS IN.
IF YOU'RE JOHN Q. CITIZEN
CALLING HIM WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT
A DV BE EITHER SIR CATIA RE
CERTIFICATION.
IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY.
GET TO THE RIGHT HUMAN BEING GET
AN ANSWER IS THIS IS AN WHATEVER
TRIED THAT IT IT CALVET.
ACTUALLY I HAVE NOT DONE THAT
PERSONALLY SIR.
BUT I HAVE SPOKE TO DIFFERENT.
VETERANS THAT ACTUALLY IT
CURRENTLY WE ARE ASSISTING AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT IN MY SHORT TIME
AS THE NEW STATE ADVOCATE.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS THAT.
THAT IS UPDATED WITH THE CURRENT
LINKS AND PHONE NUMBERS A POINT
OF CONTACT SO WE HAVE A FAX YOU
KNOW HOW TO BECOME CERTIFIED WE
HAVE A FACT SHEET ON HOW TO DO
BUSINESS.
WITH ARE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH A LOT IT.
ACTUALLY IF IF YOU ITS THE
DISAFFECTION THAT BE GREAT BUT I
RECOMMEND THAT YOU AT SOME POINT
SOMEBODY IT CALVET.
WHO'S ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
DVB EASE JUST JUST TRY TO BE AT
THE V. B. E. FOR THREE OR FOUR
DAYS AND TRY TO GET AN ANSWER.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY REALLY HARD
REALLY REALLY HARD.
SO.
I AGREE HAVING SAID THAT I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
AND OF ULTIMATELY GOT A SCRAM SO
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WATER.
NO CONCERNS I'M JUST WOULD
REITERATE --
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING IN OUR
CONVERSATION THE DEPARTMENT THAT
THIS UNIT WOULD ALSO ASSIST AND
MONITORING COMPLIANCE --
AS IT RELATES TO THIS STATE
AUDITS BUT OVERALL.
SIR YES SIR YES MA'AM JUST
BRIEFLY I DID.
I TRIED TO THINK OF THE BEST WAY
TO EXPLAIN THIS BUT IN A
MILITARY CONTEXT IT'S LIKE A
FIFTEEN SIX OFFICER MAY BE DRAWN.
THEY MAY BE A TANKER THEY MAY BE
AN INFANTRYMAN THEY MAY BE AS
SUB MARINER WHO KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
THEY'RE DRAWN AND TASKED WITH AN
INVESTIGATION WE DO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE TEAM.
THAT SPECIALIZED TO UNDERTAKE
SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS LIKE YOU
MENTIONED SIR DID LIKE HOW DO WE
CHECK OUR INTERNAL QUALITY AND
SO FORTH.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BCP IS
REALLY ABOUT IS TO GET.
FOLKS RATHER THAN HAVE IT BE
DONE AT HAWK.
SO JUST USING THE MILITARY
ANALOGY.
SO IF IF ONE PRETENDS TO BE A
PRIVATE IS NOT BEING PAID.
THEN YOU SAY I'M PRIVATE STUFFY
TRIED TO GET PAID AND YOU FIND
OUT THAT.
THERE'S BASICALLY.
NO WAY FOR SOMEONE.
THE FINANCE OFFICE PERSON IS THE
FINANCE OFFICER.
THEN IS RESPONSIBLE NOT JUST
HELP PRIVATE SNUFFY BUT ALSO
CREATE A SYSTEM SO WHEN PRIVATE
SNUFFY DOESN'T GET PAID.
THAT HE OR SHE CAN CALL SOMEBODY
DIRECTLY AND SAY I'VE NOT BEEN
PAID.
VERSUS TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW.
GO ONLINE LARA SEVENTEEN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET PAID. TO
ANALOGY IS WITH IN THAT WORKS
WITH THE ENVY TO BY THE WAY.
THE REALITY IS WITH DVB EASE IF
YOU SAY HEY I'D LIKE TO BE A D.
V. B. E..
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THERE'S A
NUMBER?
AND YOU CALL IT.
THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT DOESN'T
WORK.
OR THAT YOU SPEND MANY DAYS
TRYING TO GET TO A HUMAN BEING
FOR GENERALLY HELPFUL IT'S JUST
THAT THERE'S A SYSTEMIC ISSUE.
THAT NEEDS TO GET RESULT OF SALT
LADEN VERSE RIGHT YES THINGS ARE
WORKING ON YES AND WE'RE WORKING
ON THAT SIR THANK YOU.
BUT WE ARE ONE MORE MY ITEM WE
NEED.
TO DISCUSS OKAY SO MOVES.
CENTER DORADO YES SENATOR
NIELSEN SENATOR UMBERG LET'S SEE
LET'S SLOW DOWN --
LET'S LET'S TAKE IT UP HERE.
OKAY WE CAN PUT IT OFF.
WELL THEY'RE THEY'RE HERE SO.
WHAT ARE THEY ASKING --
FOR WOULD PLAY FOUR MILLION.
NINE PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT SECURITY OPERATIONS
CENTER [inaudible]
FIRST CYBER.
OVERALL WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
WELL --
LET'S SEE WHAT FINANCE IN LA --
HAVE TO SAY.
I SPEAK LOUD ENOUGH IS THAT OKAY.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME ALL THIS
REALLY SHORT --
GOOD AFTERNOON OR YOU WILL GET A
LITTLE [inaudible]
DO.
I'M IN A TECHNOLOGY DIRECTOR AND
JOINING ME CHIEF DEPUTY TO YEAH
CHRIS CREWS AND YOU'VE
ADMINISTRATIVE OFF.
A MILES BURNETT TO WE CAN GO
RIGHT INTO QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
B. C. PEAS THAT WE HAVE
SUBMITTED FOR THE SECURITY
OPERATION CENTERS.
AND WE JUST LEAVE IT AND MAKE IT
OPEN THAT WAY.
OKAY DO YOU YOU DO YEAH IT'S
BASICALLY BY THE DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE STATEWIDE ENTERPRISE
NETWORK AND THAT NETWORK IN
THESE POSITIONS ARE ALLOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO THIS
DEPARTMENTAL IN TERMS OF
MITIGATING MONITORING AND
MANAGING EFFECTIVELY ANY
SECURITY INTRUSIONS OUR
VULNERABILITY SO LIKE FISCAL ALL
YOU HAVE.
X. AMOUNT OF RESOURCES DEVOTED
TO FISCAL AND THAT'S A
IDENTIFIABLE NUMBER ALSO HOLDS
AN ENTERPRISE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
THE NINE POSITIONS WERE ASKING
FOR WILL DO THE TRIAGE AND DO
DILIGENCE FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
WHITE NETWORK THIS CALLOUS ONE
COMPONENT OF THAT NETWORK.
SO THEY WOULD BE SPREADING
DIVERSIFIED THROUGH THE EXISTING
PROCESS.
BUT THE POSITIONS ARE PHYSICALLY
LOCATED AT THE SECURITY
OPERATION RIGHT INTERNET IT'S
IT'S PHYSICALLY PARTY CD KEYS
BUDGET COST.
SO IT'S NOT ALLOCATED DISPERSED
TO THOSE ACTUAL UNITS IT'S
ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY CENTRAL.
YEAH SIR COST RECOVERY PROCESS
THAT WE GET THE FUNDING FOR THE
EXISTING FUNDING.
OKAY YOU HAVE TO INDULGE MY
IGNORANCE --
SO SO FOR EXAMPLE.
JUST USING FISCAL SO THIS CALL
YOU HAVE SOME SORT OF
CYBERSECURITY.
FUNCTION WITH RESPECT TO FISCAL
RIGHT.
IS THAT RIGHT.
YES I I I BELIEVE I IF THEY MEET
LIVE RIGHT AS A TRY SO EACH OF
DEPARTMENT INCLUDING DEPARTMENTS
SUCH AS A DISCOUNT HAVE THEIR
OWN.
RESPECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR SECURITY HOWEVER
WHEN IT COMES TO ENTERPRISE
LEVEL THE PROMINENT TECHNOLOGY
DOES PROVIDE THE OVER.
I'D LIKE A DECISION A LAYER
UMBRELLA IF YOU WOULD TO OVERSEE
WHAT THEY DO AS WELL AS
MONITORING WHAT THEY DO.
IN THIS PARTICULAR SONS THAT THE
SECURITY OPERATION OPERATIONS
CENTER IS THE CENTRAL MONITORING
WHEN IT COMES TO AUTO TRAFFIC IN
AND OUT AT THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
THAT INCLUDES DEPARTMENTS SUCH
AS THE SCALE WAS LIKE A TIERED
APPROACH.
SO THE PORTION THAT IS ALLOCATED
GET THIS GAL FOR WHAT THEY DO
IT'S A COST RECOVERY A
PERSPECTIVE THE HOW WE COST
RECOVER THE THE THE FUNDING THAT
WE EXPAND ON IT BUT THE
PERSONNEL.
OF MANAGING THAT HERE YOU KNOW
HIGHER LEVEL TIER WE SITES
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WE SICK COST
RECOVERY ANOTHER WOULD YOU TELL
FISCAL HATE.
WITNESS RIGHT WITH IT COST US A
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO PROVIDE SOME
SORT OF SERVICE RIGHT TO YOU.
AND THAT'S AN IDENTIFIABLE
NUMBER IS THAT RIGHT OKAY.
OKAY THAT'S THAT THAT IS MY
QUESTION AND IDENTIFIABLE NUMBER --
IT IS PART OF THE YEAR ENDS UP
BEING PART OF YOUR BUDGET OR
FISCAL ITS BUDGET.
YOUR BUDGET OKAY.
IT'S LIKE HAVING THE HOLDING IN
A GATED COMMUNITY RATE.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL GATE THIS
CALL HAVE TO IDENTIFY IT IN
ORDER.
TO GET A GIVE A BACK TO EACH
DEPARTMENT SUCH AS HAS FOR THE
GALS THE SCALE WOULD HAVE A WAY --
TO REIMBURSE US ALTHOUGH THEY DO
HAVE INCLUDED IN THEIR OWN PLACE
WOULD SB COULDN'T THAT'S MY
QUESTION AND WILL NOT A BUDGET-AUGMENTATION FOR THEM IS JUST AN
EXPENDITURE.
RIGHT SO LIKE ANY OTHER
EXPENDITURES AN EXPENDITURE
THEY'RE GOING YOUR KERR --
FOR YOUR CORRECTIVE SURPRISES SO
WE'RE A WARRANT OPPRESSORS WORK
COST RECOVERY ORGANIZATION SO WE
HAVE A A BUDGET RIGHT BUT WE
HAVE TO GO OUT AND RAISE THAT
AND REVENUE THROUGH OUR CLIENTS
RIGHT SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
MAYBE THE CHAIR.
ALSO WENT WE'RE GIVING A POT OF
MONEY TO ONE ENTITY RIGHT FOR
GIVING AND THAT ENTITY IS GOING.
TO PAY YOU SOME AMOUNT OF MONEY
GOING TO PART OF THEIR BUDGET IS
GOING YOU WHICH IS FINE I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE THE
PROCESS AND IT WAS SUCH A LARGE
PIECE OF THAT THAT THAT PRETTY
BURDEN ON THEM THEY WOULD GO TO
FINANCE A LOOK FOR SOME.
KIND OF AUGMENTATION ON THEIR
END RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GOOD.
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
A FOR NOTHING.
ALL YOUR TIME OKAY ALL RIGHT WE
NEED A MOTION AS YOU WALK OUT
SENATOR.
SO MOVED OKAY SENATOR ALSO YES
CENTER NIELSEN FENDER AMBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM OKAY I THINK THIS IT.
THOUGH CLOSING REMARKS.
LAUGHING.
ALL RIGHT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY EVEN EVERYBODY WHO
LEFT. FOR ALL YOUR SERVICES WE
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT.
I DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH